Even though it's early in the morning.
I did the smart thing before this
podcast started and I'm muted my fucking
laptop.
So yay.
This episode of the Joe Rogan
experience is brought to you by hover.
If you go to harvard.com
forward slash is it
Joe?
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
Why don't I know this?
Um,
early.
Yeah,
it's early,
but also I don't pay attention.
I would not calm forward slash Joe.
We'll see if that comes up.
You know,
I think that that thing with getting dig
party in my mouth.com is destroying my
website.
Why is it just on your website?
How many people are going like,
what the Flexdek party in my mouth?
Well,
listen man,
they just need to deal
with it is what it is.
It's a dig party in my mind.
There was awesome.
What?
Ari's legs or something like that.
Or He's sexy legs.
Dot.
Yeah.
What was that?
What else?
What else did we do?
Well,
there was one other one too.
Ari.
Ari Shaffir,
his legs.com and a,
what's that means like Jen
was trying to say is that we,
um,
hover.com forward slash
world and that's what it is.
You get 10% off.
We register websites like during
the commercial it's so easy to use.
Hover is so intuitive that we're register
websites during the commercial and
then forward them to our actual websites
but their websites like tick party in
your mouth.com you know,
and that's not smart to have that
point into your fucking we do business
especially if Uncle Sam
comes looking at Ya,
you know Uncle Sam's like what's
wrong with this freak bitch?
He's got Dick Party in your mouth.com
leading to is subversive website with cats
all over the place anyway,
however.com forward
slash Rogen place to go.
Super easy setup and they offer you free
stuff that a lot of people charge for.
Like who is domain name privacy?
Super easy to do.
I have personally used
it to register websites,
so go and check it out.
And if you go to hover.com
forward slash Rogen,
you can get 10% off your
domain name registrations
were also brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is um,
uh,
one of our newer sponsors,
but it's something I'm really excited
about it because I just love what you can
do with it.
I love that someone,
anyone can make their own website and
you can do it just as easily as he could
set up a Facebook page.
It's,
it's awesome and you don't have to pay
to try it out so you can give it a shot.
It's like they're so confident,
they're like,
you don't have to pay for it.
It's come on,
sign up,
try it out.
And if you're looking to make
a website you will definitely,
definitely want to try this.
And you definitely not want to go
to cock in come mouth@hotmail.com
well it's gone anyway.
Now is it gone?
Wow.
I think Arisa fear actually highly gone.
I think they just got to rid of it and
Ari Shaffir it has that still has a
hotmail address and I've been telling
him seriously for like 10 years like
please stop,
you got to get off this thing.
They're going to close.
It isn't a Microsoft
don't they own hotmail?
Microsoft close anything
cause it's called hotmail.
They probably wouldn't really branded
I think hotmails Badass.
There's nothing wrong with it.
I liked an IRA.
That's a meme right there.
[inaudible]
I was a late abandoned or of all,
what can I say?
I think the way things are,
I'm good with it.
Hot meals.
Okay with me man.
Um,
anyway,
Squarespace you can go and set
up any kind of website you want.
You can start your own business.
Like it's super easy to set up a
store and just start selling shit.
It's really a,
a pretty dope website and
you can try it for free.
Go to squarespace.com forward slash Joe
and a use the offer code Joe five cause
it's
time is flying son.
Use the offer code Joe Five and you
will save 10% off your first purchase.
On a new accounts including
monthly and annual plan.
So that's squarespace.com forward slash
Joe and we are also sponsored each and
every week by on it.com and if you go to
o n n I t and use the code name Rogan,
you'll save 10% off any of the supplements
if you haven't been there in a while.
We got a lot of crazy shit there
that we sell besides a supplements.
We started to sell kettlebells,
we shipping to people.
I think we've,
we're even shipping them overseas now.
We sell all kinds of nutty,
a strength and conditioning equipment
and like steel maces and steel clubs and
weight vests and I'll shut that
gives you like functional strength.
Like if you want to have functional
strength like Dan Hardee,
you want to be that kind of savage.
I like this quote,
powerful Joe Rogan
label,
like a seal of approval.
Hilarious.
That's power.
That's sort of tongue in cheek cheek.
Um,
but it is that that will kick
your dick write in the dirt.
That is a brutal fucking workout.
Extreme kettlebell cardio workout.
He's got two of them.
This guy,
Keith,
Keith Weber.
I'm one of them.
Uh,
I've,
I haven't done a number two,
which is supposed to be more crazy,
but number one,
I can barely get through
with a 35 pound kettle bell.
It's fucking ferocious.
But 45 minutes in,
you're just ready to die.
You can't put,
cause this bitch gets to take breaks.
Okay.
He does it.
He films it and then cuts.
Okay.
But then the fucking video keeps
going and then he starts up off fresh.
Like the dude had a Gatorade,
got its foot massage.
Fuck you Keith Weber.
I know you ain't that fit,
bitch.
Nobody's at fit.
That shit's ridiculous.
Only joking around sir.
I think it Kettlebell TVDs amazing.
My point is,
um,
uh,
I've used it with a 35 pound
Kettlebell and it's fucking,
it's unbelievably tough.
It's great.
And uh,
it's a full body strength type of thing.
We also have,
uh,
the,
the new chimpanzee kettlebells,
it,
that everyone's
talking about.
Uh,
if you haven't seen him,
primal bells,
they're the first in a series of kettle
bells that were going to release that
are all art based.
It's all,
we hired an artist to
create some cool things on.
And kettlebells,
we actually,
you know,
the,
the idea behind it came from,
there's a,
another company on the
web called Demon Bells.
They have it.
And we were like,
Ooh,
like that you could draw on your weights.
you know,
you can create art.
And so we hired the special
effects designer and uh,
they made this and they made,
we've,
we've got some crazy ones coming up.
We've got to gorilla coming out.
She'd make an angry birds wind so we
could like throw them at each other.
Angry birds once we've got
a whole series of them.
I can't tell you,
I can't really say any pictures,
but they're going to look awesome.
Just like this.
Chimp does is chimp is
a scary looking fucker.
Um,
and uh,
anyway,
go to [inaudible] Dot Com oh and end it.
And again,
if you use a code,
Rogan,
you'll save 10% off
any of the supplements,
aren't you?
Freaks Dan.
Hardee's here.
Kirk,
don't tell.
Talk a shit underneath the commercial.
What are you doing son?
I iPads disabled.
I know you're tired.
Keep it together.
Your iPad went down,
your iPad is disabled for five minutes.
I'm like,
what the fuck it does this,
the government,
the downloading your,
your identity.
They saw Dick Party in my mouth.
Dot Com
experience
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Awful.
Dan Hardee that's up buddy.
Thanks for coming by man.
I'm very excited to have this
conversation with you and uh,
the Internet has been a buzz,
you know?
Yeah,
it's been something misunderstood,
dude,
man.
You know.
Yeah,
I think so.
A lot of people,
uh,
especially seeing your
trash talking and you know,
hype it up like the GSP fight
and knock the fake Tan off you.
People would think that you're an asshole.
You're not an asshole at all.
You look,
you're a super chill guy.
Like I never,
I don't think I've ever been
around you and felt like,
wow,
that's sad hardy.
It's just too much.
I've got to get the fuck away from him.
He was like a really
easy to get along with.
You're a very friendly guy.
You just are really good at talking shit
when it comes down to fight time and
pissing people off.
And that really is something
that people have to understand.
You know,
like this is a pageantry involved in
promoting a fight and in fucking with
someone's head that you're
going to fight and it's,
it's,
people don't like it when other people
are better at that aspect of fighting.
You know,
they get mad.
People get mad if you could talk mad
shit about them if they're not good at
talking shit back.
Ah,
they go into the fight with
it like a deficit already.
It's kind of crazy.
It was the culture I was bull open though.
You know,
like,
you know,
banter between teammates at rough
house is pretty much bullying.
I mean it gets pretty serious like to
where I'm sure some of the guys go home
and cry after the session,
you know?
So it's just kind of a
natural thing for me.
And then when somebody bites a little
bit to a comment that I made,
I can't help myself.
It's too much fun.
That's,
it's very English.
It's very similar to Boston.
And that way Boston has that same like,
you know,
real and insulting style to the trash
talk within sports teams and athletes and
it's just part of the whole thing.
And some people don't like it.
And I could get that.
I get that there's some people want
that zen state Anderson Silva approach.
We just go in.
But people forget about
Anderson Silva in Abu Dhabi.
They forget when he was,
when he was fighting
with Damien Maia talking,
I'm calling them all kinds
of shit and Portuguese.
He was fucking with that dude's
head while he was lighting him up,
you know?
Yeah.
That's even crazy crap.
Trash talk.
The trash talk that goes on while
you're kicking someone's ass.
I remember watching him
fight and Lee Marie,
um,
I was,
I was at the side of the cage about
fine and the Tony Fryklund one.
Oh Dude,
you were there for that.
Oh my God.
People who haven't seen Anderson Silva
became Anderson Silva when he went to
Japan and when he went to England.
But England was really where
it all came together for him.
You know,
like Japan,
he got some good fights,
but he had some losses.
You know the real tone in he flying.
He'll hook.
Yeah.
I mean he had some good fights.
Um,
who's that kid who was
calling him Alex de bling?
The kid was called himself
the Brazilian killer.
Remember they all got pissed off at him.
Anderson,
he beat him.
He caught him with a,
with a high kick and then
he knocked out Carlos Dude.
And that was probably what's most
spectacular fight over there.
But he fly in new ones.
Yeah.
And it was after Carlos
dominated them on the ground.
Carlos is very good,
very advanced at that time.
Like he had like the most
advanced ground game of,
of guys that were fighting and high
level and he had an Anderson Downhill
Mountain,
him and it did not look,
Eric Anderson was getting up.
Um,
but I think they gave him a yellow
card or something like that.
I Dunno how they got stood back up again.
I don't know what happened,
but they've got stuff back up again
and he hit him with a flying knee and
knocked him out.
And it was after that.
He like,
he got his footing with
a couple of good fights,
but it wasn't until he went to
England and font and cage rage.
That's when he became Anderson Silva.
It was so comfortable.
It was,
I really felt watching the limb or
fight that he could have stopped it.
And if any point,
you know,
you were ready to just kind of told,
treat him a little bit,
beaten him up.
He was tough.
He was beating the fuck out of Lima.
Yeah,
he was fucking his legs up man.
And you know,
and Maria is tough as shit.
He hung in there man,
the entire time.
38 times though.
So it was training.
Six weeks later he made a video about
him hitting the mid six weeks later,
if,
if people don't know
who we're talking about,
this guy is like really a
legitimate folk lore type character.
He's like Guy Ritchie movie character.
Yeah,
he and he's almost greater than a guy
Ritchie character because you wouldn't
ever believe a Guy Ritchie character
really could be like a top MMA fighter and
also one of the greatest armed robbery
suspects in the history of the universe
right now.
He's pretty crazy.
I remember sitting in traffic
on the way to cage rage.
I,
uh,
pulled daily in the car and uh,
like stuck in traffic but not far from
the arena and Lemuria just racing up the
hard shoulder and he's,
and he's a,
I think it was a BMW s
like 70 miles an hour.
Just,
he was crazy.
Did you see him following that with
Matt Lindland after that fight?
Uh,
Lindland for a cage rage and they brought
Marie into kind of hype up a fight
between the two.
Yeah.
[inaudible] your fucking mind key.
You're a lot like a fucking monkey.
There was Matt Lindland was just,
he didn't even think it was real.
It was,
it was pretty hilarious.
The more he's like throwing
stuff at him while he was real.
He just really,
was that crazy?
Yeah.
There's every now and then a
dude comes along like that.
Yeah.
You know,
we're lucky that he didn't
come along and like,
like the dark ages,
you know what I mean?
I mean he would have showed
the web people like him.
Fuck yeah,
there were that guy would have had like
the scariest gang ever back when there
was like very little rules.
You can have swords and shit.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
It'll run like a bunch
of outliers in a forest.
You got to think,
man,
that time in our lives in the,
for the human race,
that was only like a thousand years ago.
That's not that long ago,
man.
It's like medieval shit.
Long ago.
That's so,
so recent.
The DNA is still there,
public beheadings and every now and
then he gets some straight lineage type
shit.
You get a dude who just has basically
barbarian means and he's walking amongst
regular folks here in 2013 he just,
he's not playing by any rule.
She's got no rules.
He's just going for it
until he hits a wall,
just full clip until he hits a wall.
It's important to know that it's possible
that a guy like that could exist and
people get romantic about it and upset,
but you could not get
upset about it today.
You can got knocked,
get romantic about it till you could,
you know,
say,
Oh,
you know,
you're glorifying something that you're
glorifying something pathetic and it
would,
if this guy inspires other
kids to live that way,
okay.
But make no mistake about
it a hundred years from now,
it's going to be an awesome story.
Okay.
200 years ago when you're not connected.
Yeah.
From now,
like when we're not
connected to it emotionally.
It's going to be an awesome
story.
But we studied these people now though.
I mean look at like a,
you know,
like,
like Branson or a lot of folks
don't know that documentary.
The Bronson documentary.
It was really weird.
Yeah.
Chopper was really weird too.
But those are there,
those kinds of people like Lemur.
He's got to have a movie made about him.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
Unquestionably.
And he could fucking fight,
man.
He could fight.
I saw him a fight.
Amir Renova rd starched him,
man.
It was so ruthless.
His right hand was fucking nasty.
He was really,
really sharp.
Stryker,
really powerful guy.
I mean he wasn't like
the most technical guy,
which is where Andy
should pick them apart.
You know.
He was such fast hands though.
He was very fast and very confident,
very confident.
You know it took a guy like
Anderson to sort of pick them apart.
A guy who just was clearly
Anderson's on some nothing.
He's not some next level
in like every department.
Yeah he's on some next
level physical shit.
He's up some next level mental shit.
He's on some next level
of confidence shit.
He's on some next level success shit.
He really feels like he's magic.
He feels like he can go in there and
just do shit to people but he can,
he can.
He does.
You're right.
So He's like that.
It takes a guy like that to do
that until a guy like Lee Marie,
you know a guy like when when you see
Anderson like at its best is one of the
weirdest things cause you can't
believe a guy can do what he just did.
You know,
like when he fucked up when we were there
in Brazil and he fought Stephan Bonner
dude,
that was like,
I was watching a movie.
Yeah.
It was like the guy just put his back
to the cage and let him tee off on them
and then brought him back in,
got to the center and
brought them right back in,
puts his hands down,
stands right in front of them,
and then when he decides to strike,
throws him to the ground and buries him
with one knee and you're like Jesus.
But it was like the Forrest
Griffin fight though.
He'd been baiting him to like,
like overextend on his punches
all the way through the round.
And then as soon as he did
it and crossed his feet,
he just seems surreal.
Yeah,
he's a master.
He's a real master.
It's kind of a kind of an honor
to be around witnessing it live.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I agree.
It's an honor to be able
to call it for short.
It's,
it's really shocking.
His abilities are very shocking,
but you know,
one day we're going to look back at him
and we're going to look at some new guy.
It just,
the way people used to look at
Sugar Ray Robinson and Roy Jones Jr.
Yeah,
she,
Ray Robinson was amazing,
but I think Roy Jones Jr in his prime
would've lit them up with like a Christmas
tree.
I don't think he would have
even been able to fuck with him.
Like he wouldn't have
been able to find him.
But I look at Mayweather.
Yeah.
As much as I disliked the guy.
Beautiful boxer.
Beautiful Roy.
The problem with Roy was
all that John Ruiz fight.
He went up and wait in
one heavyweight fight.
That documentary was good though.
Did you watch it?
What is it?
The documentary I am writing for that.
Oh No,
no,
I didn't.
It was,
it was really interesting.
It got this little old white
dude doing all of these uh,
strength and conditioning.
Wow.
What was it?
Mackey shall stone.
Is that his name?
Mackey.
She'll stone is the guy.
Let me see if I can pull it up.
He's the guy who trained,
um,
he trained,
uh,
Spinks Michael Spinks for is
heavyweight fights with Larry Holmes.
And then again for Tyson I think.
Huh.
Yeah,
I remember watching a,
it was one of the,
one of the HBO shows tone at one of the
HBO shows with the Roy Jones prepare for
a fight.
And it was when I was training
the legends and there was this,
this shot where he was training to run
DMC and he's like doing any ShutterBox
into the rhythm of the music.
So I was immediately downloaded run DMC
and started doing it at the gym legend.
Oh yeah,
he,
yeah,
he worked with Roy Jones.
Yeah,
he was,
he was an interesting card.
Said well it's interesting because
what happened was then Roy,
he looks spectacular in the Ruiz fight,
but then he drops down to fight Antonio
Tarver his to lose a lot of ways.
Yeah.
Cause he's a 205 pound,
206 pound guy now.
I mean he was a small heavyweight,
but I think he's still,
he got above 200 pounds,
which to drop all the way the
fuck down to one 75 again,
that is a big deal.
It is.
It's way easier to talk your body and
to getting bigger than it is to talk to
you about and to getting smaller.
Yeah.
Like you have to fucking starve yourself,
especially in a sport like boxing where
you've got to continuously work for a
long period of time.
Yeah.
He looked completely different
in that fight physically.
Like his body looked deflated,
you know,
cutting weight like that.
It just ruined him.
And then he got knocked out by Tarver
and then he got knocked out again,
even scarier by Glenn Johnson and those,
those fights,
I think direct result of him weakening
himself to drop down to 175 pounds or a
direct result also of whatever the fuck
he took to get up to 200 plus pounds not
being in the system anymore.
And his system crashes,
which is what happens,
especially if you're like
in your late thirties yeah.
And you,
you're a pro athlete who's getting
head trauma on a regular basis?
Well those were all things designed
to lower your testosterone.
All of those things,
you know,
it's almost like nature has it set up
like you're going to get hit in the head
so many times for it just
start slow the fuck down bitch.
Jesus Christ like literally slows down
your testosterone from head trauma.
It's like,
look,
we got to figure out a way to stop
getting hit in the head and maybe this
asshole to add row
nature doesn't know that.
You've got to fucking fight
and career to think about.
Yeah,
I hated watching him fight cows.
Aggie.
Yeah.
Did you like how's that guy?
Either and they was just,
it was just rough to watch.
He's a shell of himself.
I don't think cows,
I could have hung with Roy
and when Roy was in his prime,
when Roy fought Vinny Pazienza,
it was the first fight ever recorded
where the opponent did not land a single
punch.
He went through a whole round boxing with
Vinny Pazienza when patsy Hans was in
its prime.
And pass the hands of swinging for
fucking fences and get nothing for a whole
round.
I mean,
that's insane.
You're,
you're in the both punch in and this guy
hits you 60 times and you hit him zero.
That's insane.
Should we should get Anderson
Silva to break that record,
like number of punches
based that around us.
Well you,
what you need with an Anderson Silva,
you're going to need a Roy Jones
type dude to beat Anderson Silva.
You're going to need a guy
who's got that kind of,
but with Moy Tai it,
those guys are out there.
Man,
they're out there.
They just got to put it together.
We all knew like you,
you came up doing martial arts
like a good portion of your life,
right?
So you must've went to like
karate tournament is a solid,
those few young kids that weren't super
talented where everybody was like God
damn,
but sometimes they never come to fruition.
You know,
they never become the martial arts
legends that they could have been.
In my experience without the people that
find it that easy and pick it up that
quickly.
Usually you usually lose interest.
It's kind of frustrating.
There's a very few that stick
with it and that's when you get someone
like Anderson Silva or John Jones.
Yeah.
There's those guys who have that lethal
combination of like dedication and that
freaks skill and freak bodies.
Man Do some freak shit.
Yeah.
There's certain dudes,
they're like,
John Jones can do some
freak shit to people,
you know,
like he can,
he's spitting elbows.
People in the head,
he's giant.
You can't get ahold of them.
He out wrestled [inaudible] though any,
I mean,
I can't imagine,
I can't imagine throwing any strike
home that wouldn't hit something sharp.
Doesn't mean it'd be like
kicking a bag of ranches.
Yeah.
He's fucking scary dude.
Scary right now.
He's on this next level,
scary shit right now where he's
just dis like so confident.
Just like the science,
the mall,
chill son.
And he's like 15
I think he just turned 24 25 okay.
Yeah.
Well,
it is a young man's game.
It is.
What is the,
this condition that pulled
you out of your next fight?
Um,
the wolf hot thing.
What is it called?
Like a baboon heart.
Yeah.
It's exactly the same.
What is,
what is,
uh,
what does it mean?
It's called Wolff
Parkinson White Syndrome.
But I didn't have the syndrome
because I've never had any symptoms.
I only have pattern,
which means that I ha I
have a second heartbeat,
but it's not never caused a problem.
You have a second heartbeat.
Yeah.
Well basically,
uh,
you know,
in the center of your heart you've got
like the regular pacemaker is a bunch of
skills that a bunch of cells that um,
you know,
they create electrical impulse to,
to keep the heart beating.
And with WPW people have,
uh,
other cells in the upper parts of
the hall that did the same thing.
And usually what they
would do is they go in,
it's called an ablation.
They kind of go into the femoral artery
and they can burn them out and stuff.
But that's,
but people will have that done when they,
when they have like symptoms,
you know,
when they have like palpitations
or dizziness and like
people have panic attacks
and stuff.
I've never had anything.
Nothing at all.
So what,
that's what they're
telling me at the moment.
I mean,
I've got to go back and get some,
uh,
some more tests done for like a second
opinion with a different person.
Um,
but basically what the,
what the way I understand it right now
is if I want to continue fighting to get
cleared,
I have to have the ablation.
But because I've never had any
symptoms and I'm perfectly fine,
I don't see the point in letting
someone go in and start burning my shit.
And that doesn't sound,
that sounds like something they were
probably not going to do in five years.
They're going to go,
well back when we used to
go in there and burn it out,
we realized that's actually
a mistake that was actually,
you know,
the human body figured it
out and everything was cool
and running smooth and we
were being ridiculous.
Yeah.
I mean,
if it was causing that problem
and that's the solution,
then I would have it done.
But it's not.
So their concern is that if
they license you and this,
this is a potential issue,
a health issue,
while those,
there was that soccer
player a few years ago,
I think you play flight Chelsea or
something and he had a heart attack on the
pitch and died.
He was like 28.
Um,
I'm basically,
the problem is that the,
the main heart rate can only go
up to about 220 beats a minute.
But the secondary cells that produce a a,
the second heart rate or the heartbeat
is that's limitless that can go to,
to whatever.
So,
you know,
like if I'm at 12 minutes into the
fight and I'm full of adrenaline and
completely exhausted and my
heart rate can't keep up,
there's a potential for the
other one to kind of take over,
you know,
and he'd give you a hard time.
Yeah.
But it,
but you know,
the chances decrease after 25 and the
chance of it happening is like 0.6%.
So,
you know.
Yeah.
Well do you also have like a
really low resting heart rate?
Yeah.
42 that's very,
it was when I got the tests.
Michael Bisping's is like 34.
Yeah.
That's insane.
That's incredible,
man.
It doesn't have to feed his brain.
They don't forget.
Oh No,
you didn't basically knows.
I'm kidding.
He might have like the lowest
rate working heart rate,
the resting heart rate
of anybody in the UFC.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That was pretty impressive work.
You only get that from work.
He's that Kinda guy that
he's always like switched on.
You know what I mean?
So yeah.
That's a,
that's a fit mother fucker.
Yeah.
It's very interesting what you said about
like natural talent and then the guys
with natural talent.
It's oftentimes they're the ones who
for whatever reason don't work as hard.
Well,
[inaudible] was,
the best thing was that guy
that had the talent and yeah,
he's,
he's just a natural fighter.
His whole family.
I just tough guys.
Um,
I mean,
I started training with Mike
before he'd even out of,
at his first fight.
Um,
and I was training with his coach and
his coach had actually invested money in
like bringing him down to
Nottingham to train to like,
cause he was a DJ at the time.
I don't know whether most
people know this but you know,
Dj Mikey B
and um,
you know,
he was like in that,
the,
the dance and the rave scene and he was,
you know,
all that kind of stuff.
The glow sticks and shit.
Um,
yeah.
So,
so my instructor like,
like bought my car and brought him down
to Nottingham and like fed him and stuff
it with the intention of,
of making him an MMA star because he
had this natural ability and he is,
he's a,
he's just a tough guy.
He's a very tough guy.
You know,
he knocked the dude out,
he gets up and he's like,
I want a rematch.
Like immediately.
Yeah,
it's pretty interesting.
I think he's,
that guy doesn't lose
any steam if he loses.
Like he's just goes back
to the drawing board,
dusts himself off,
heals up and has exactly the same style.
The next fight.
Yeah.
He's got a sprinkling of that Bob Barry.
And then
there's a lot of that shit out there,
man.
Well,
I left barbarian blood.
It's out there.
So,
um,
what are you going to do now?
No.
Wow.
Uh,
I'm going to go back and get some,
some more tests done.
Lorenzo has,
uh,
a special cardiologist that
he wants me to go and see,
so I'm going to get that done and uh,
just kind of see what my options are.
I don't,
I don't see the point in
having a surgery done if I,
if I have to have it done
to carry on fighting.
It seems scary.
It just seems pointless to me.
Especially because,
you know,
like is it risky?
Well,
the problem is that they don't
know whereabouts in my heart it is.
Oh,
Jesus.
I think gotta go look,
I'll look for it.
So they didn't say they could fix it
or they said they wanted to study it.
They want to study it.
I study and they wanted to study
this for weeks before the fight,
so they wanted me to go in and have uh,
something put up the inside archery at
both my legs and wanting to my neck so
they can go in and try and find it.
They put you under
while you're doing this.
Are you just chilling?
Oh fuck.
Is that Dan?
Hardee how's that possible?
You just lie in there.
So yeah,
that's just not cool.
Yeah,
that is so not cool.
So the guy was like,
oh,
so we'll do that and if we can find it,
we can fix it and then you'll be able to,
you know,
take a week off and then
go back to training.
Who the fuck?
You could just chill while they send
these like wire worms up your arteries or
peek inside your fucking heart.
My Dad said get that thing up his penis
hole when like when he turned a certain
age,
I think it's 60 in your penis.
Definitely.
Fuck that.
I had people tweeting me
and stuff and they're like,
uh,
you know,
my six year old had it done.
Stop being such a pussy and go home and
we have more than one.
There's people that just can't wait to
be country down and you got to feel sorry
for them because I'm like a
magnet for the course you are.
You're a brash young man.
He talked a lot of shit and people they,
that's how they,
one of the things that
people like about it,
it generates interest and how much
hate jail Santa must get all day,
every day,
all day,
every his Twitter must be a mess.
But he's got the bank
accounts and match it though.
Sorry.
So that's what,
that's the problem with me know.
Yeah.
He really talked himself
into some great situations.
He's,
he's the best shit talker ever.
He's exciting to watch.
I love like interviewing him in a way in,
because I know he's going
to say some crazy shit.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the kind of shit it's
going to go down in history,
this thing.
Yeah.
I always remember one line and he said
when he was preparing for a Anderson,
I'm not sure which time it was,
and he said,
here's the champion,
but I am the best.
Yeah,
that's a great line.
I just,
I want to use that
every day at some point.
I mean,
and he's so good.
Even after he loses in insulin,
another fight like that,
just think about what happened to dude
got starched by Anderson Silva and then
he says,
you know what,
Anderson Silva is only the beginning.
I'm going to go after the
light heavyweight champion.
And like all the sudden
he's fighting the light,
every champion.
I mean,
he goes from losing a shot
at the middleweight belt
to fighting for the light
heavyweight belt.
And you know,
that's impressive.
Yeah,
it was in Dana is like,
he's the one who asked for that fight.
Like I understand that he is a politician.
Yeah,
I understand that.
He's the one that asked for that fight.
But that's a,
I mean,
you got to respect the
guy's ability to sell shit.
I mean,
he can sell a fucking paper view,
man.
I mean the dude just lost to Anderson
Silva and there was white people all over
the world
convinced that he had a shot.
Yeah.
There was white people all over the world.
It was looking forward to him winning,
you know,
he started,
what a character,
what does,
what a funny smart guy.
He's the kind of guy that could knock
on your door at like 8:00 AM and you're
like,
you wake up by battle all outside and
shit and then he's selling his time.
Makes the door and you bought
three vacuum platelets.
Yeah.
No,
but he can fight too,
man.
He can fight.
It's just he's,
he ran into to buzz saws to the,
the greatest fighters of the generation
and Anderson and mean look what he did
to Anderson the first fight that
you can't take that away from him.
Even in Spanish.
One was injured.
That was an incredible performance.
He was minutes away
from winning the title.
He fucked up in that final round,
but he was real close.
Carries that with him though.
Do you think that,
well,
it's hard to say he doesn't,
it's harder to say.
It doesn't.
Then to say does to say he does.
You can get all the evidence,
the Polo Filio fi this fight.
But the,
Oh,
the other thing is he's,
first of all,
he's just playing at a real high
level and this kind of shit happens.
You read a real fucking high level and
if you look at how it happens in every
other fight,
it happened in a way that
sort of makes sense to him.
Like Anderson Silva caught him with the
triangle that sort of makes sense to
him.
He missed that,
that spinning back fist and he got caught.
That sort of makes sense.
But the John John's fight
didn't make any sense.
The Jon Jones fight was a mauling.
John just took them down in Malden.
And I think that was like the
most disappointing for him.
Yeah.
Cause he's a very good fighter man.
If you look at the way he submitted Brian,
Stan,
you know,
that's that,
that's a scary dude.
Chill son.
It's a beast.
Oh yeah.
But those guys are just to step
better and that's what it is.
It's just a step better.
That's all they need to be.
So,
so what's your opinion on,
uh,
on,
fights is accusing each
other using steroids?
Well,
I think,
um,
we,
we both know that in every sport in
the world where there's money involved,
people are going to do everything
they can in order to be victorious.
That is just the way it is.
There are people who hold principal
higher than they hold money.
And I know for a fact I had a long
conversation with John Fitch once about it
and John Fitch,
I guarantee you that guy
never used to anything ever.
He's just,
for him it was a principle issue.
But that's not everybody.
We,
we both know it's not everybody.
A lot of guys have used stuff.
A lot of guys have used
stuff and they've said,
well,
you know,
I'm just trying to get
over an injury and uh,
of I'm just going to use it
to get over this knee injury.
Yeah,
that too,
that you're doing that too.
But also look,
you get,
you realize when you're around a certain,
around a certain amount of like
really strong wrestler type dudes,
you go,
okay,
there's nothing I can do
to keep this guy off me.
I've got to get fucking stronger period.
If I want to stay in this game,
I got to get stronger.
I don't know how the
fuck he got that strong,
but I got to get stronger and it's really
hard to get stronger naturally quick.
Naturally the shit takes a years.
You know,
it takes like four or five years to put
on a good 20 pounds of like real raw
muscle or we can do it this way and
everybody's doing it and then you go,
okay,
if everybody's doing it,
you know,
people kind of kind of justify it to
themselves because of the people that are
doing it.
You know,
it's like everybody enables each other.
Yeah.
I don't think,
um,
I think,
uh,
there's a,
certainly an issue and there's certainly
a discussion to be had and especially
in,
in for testosterone replacement therapy,
that's a big one.
That to me is a big one because that
one for a lot of folks that don't know,
like young fighters in their early
thirties even even some guys younger than
that,
uh,
take testosterone,
which is really kind of crazy.
Like your,
your body should be producing
testosterone in healthy quality quantity.
It's like deep,
deep into your thirties.
It starts to drop off when
he started hitting 40,
if you're like a very slowly,
very small numbers.
Yes.
And if you're,
if you're fit and if you're,
you're eating healthy
and if you know you're,
you sleeping right,
you should be okay.
So when you find guys that are like 30,
and they're taking testosterone
replacement therapy,
it will,
okay,
what are you doing?
What are you doing right now?
Is you're putting testosterone
into your body that doesn't exist.
So does it not exist because
you've been hit too many times,
which we both know was
also a real possibility.
In fact a,
this guy,
Dr. Mark Gordon who
worked with James Tony's,
he's done a lot of work on that,
showing how traumatic brain injury to
both soldiers and people who do extreme
sports,
that traumatic brain injury has
a significant impact on your,
your body's ability to
produce testosterone.
So I could knock the
testosterone out of somebody's,
well I don't like little girl
[inaudible] is picking that line up.
It's not,
it's not a situation where,
where it happens in one,
one night.
It's a situation where
you're beating yourself up.
You know,
if I've never fought in MMA fight,
but I've watched you guys
trained and you know,
I see the,
the amount of hours that it takes in a
day to do a real proper six week camp.
And for folks who don't know,
it's insane.
It's insane.
It's,
it's fucking madness.
And I think some guys think the only way
they can get through that is with some
help because if you
don't get through that,
then what are you going to do when
you get in there with a guy like GSP,
when you know he has gone
through that and like,
well fuck you know,
you're,
you're doomed.
You're going to keep up
with them for a little bit,
but eventually he's
going to steamroll you.
Yeah.
There's just no getting around it.
If you don't do what
everybody else is doing,
how can you compete?
Unless I dry,
it dries like an alien.
Oh,
what's,
yeah.
The thing
about aliens.
Terrified of aliens.
Yeah.
If he hates fighting dudes
with Alienware on their trunk,
what if it was Kelly and
where the whole time,
just a big marketing,
getting hired by Alienware
spots with a lot of fighters.
You know,
maybe TSP has a deal.
They can't have them wear
that thing on their pants.
They wear that thing to scare me.
No,
no.
Have you rewatched that?
Rewatch it.
It's so interesting.
It's amazing.
He's awesome.
I love that guy.
That was a beautiful interview,
man.
It really was.
He's a guy who,
uh,
he's,
he's kept his humility better
than any champion I've ever seen.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
I've been up to Montreal a couple
of times to work with them and uh,
well the first time I went up there I
didn't know how they were going to receive
me know because obviously,
you know,
I did say a few things about this camp
during the preparation and fake 10 line
was fucking outstanding.
Thank you.
Um,
yeah.
So I,
they asked me to go out for a week to
spar with him and I thought they were just
going to take me into,
to kind of beat me up a little bit,
throw me out.
But I was up for it anyway.
It was going to be an experience and when
I got there everyone was really cool.
I felt,
you know,
I was like,
yeah,
ready.
Cool.
And GSP is by far the most
humble and deserve it champion.
Other than that,
there's no,
no one liked him when it
comes to like MMA champions.
He's such a,
he's a sweet guy.
Like real nice to Pete and
he handles it really well,
his lifestyle,
because obviously it's,
he gets a lot of attention all the
time and it's exhausting and he still,
no matter how much attention he goes,
he's still the same guy.
It's not,
he doesn't fall into it.
You know,
that's,
that's a real issue with
folks fall into that,
you know,
they get caught up.
It was kind of funny going up there the
first time because I still had a Mohawk
the first time and like he
goes out like most nights,
he like loves to be
out in clubs and stuff.
He doesn't drink and any of that.
But obviously you can imagine how
much attention he gets him Montreal.
And so he's walking through the club
and everybody would like looks over him
staring at him and then they notice me
behind him and they're like the look of
confusion on their face.
Like we got hoodwinked
motherfuckers like each other.
That's funny,
man.
That's funny.
Yeah.
You know when all trickled down from
the top that for Rasa hobby guy.
Yeah,
that's smart dude.
He is.
It's a very,
very smart dude.
Very clever.
The way he runs his show is no bullshit,
you know,
and John Danaher's,
well,
people don't talk about this guy right
in the hotel that I was staying at.
My Room was opposite his.
So like he was the last
person I'd see before,
like before,
like heading to bed at night.
And we stood in that long conversations
in the corridor and the guy's
fascinating and really,
really strange,
really,
really strange and really,
really fascinating.
Um,
I went to,
we went to dinner with him,
me,
him in any bravo,
uh,
like a Denny's or some shit like that.
I then we just broke down
the universe together.
John Danaher is a beast.
He's amazing.
So,
so fucking smart.
Yeah.
And that's actually how I went.
That's how I wound up doing
the taekwondo with George.
Okay.
And teaching them how to throw
the attorney side kick correctly.
It's from John Donahoe.
Like Donna her was asking me if I
knew any high level taekwondo guys,
they can teach George the proper
mechanics of the spinning back kick.
And I felt like such
an asshole saying like,
yeah,
I can judge it.
Right.
You know,
it sounds like such a
Hollywood douche move.
Like,
Oh yeah,
you know you're going to teach George
fucking Saint Pierre how to throw a kick.
But to his credit,
he actually listened to me like
I couldn't believe he tried it.
You know,
because I wouldn't have listened to me.
I be like,
yeah,
bitch.
All right,
I'll go watch you kick a bag,
fruitcake,
what can act or Weirdo.
But George was like super like
humble and eager to learn.
He's a really unusual dude.
It's weird how many different,
like the way people perceive like MMA
fighters or even Jujitsu athletes are
kickboxers the way people perceive,
like people who compete in combat
sports and the way they really are.
It's so different.
Like my favorite people,
some of my favorite people of all time
that I've ever met have been fighters
because there's something about the type
of character that you need to have to
be able to test yourself in
such an extreme environment.
Like that's a rare quality.
It's a very real quality.
And there's some people miss mistake it
with being a barbaric thing cause they,
they think that somehow or another we
should not be violent because violence is
bad.
And even though it's a competition and
they both agree to do it and they can be
respectful,
it's still seems like it's anti societal.
Yeah.
But they don't understand they did this.
They just haven't experienced anything
like really intense themselves.
And,
and knowing that there's only one way
to develop like real character and have
confidence in that real character,
you've got to put yourself in fire.
Yeah.
And,
and that's why it,
that's why a lot of them may fight as a,
of our interest in people.
But yes,
I mean,
you know,
after a certain amount of time of being
in the gym and being so focused on
yourself,
you become very self aware and,
and then,
you know,
usually from that becomes a
lot of self confidence and,
and,
you know,
just being very comfortable in,
in different environments,
which usually means you
stand out because you,
you know,
you,
you kind of put that out there when you,
when you walk into a room.
Um,
and you're not worried about
physical confrontation,
but you will sit and feel like
you have anything to prove.
Exactly.
And that's the real issue with a lot of
guys is the need to prove dominance and
need to prove.
But guys who have had
martial arts backgrounds,
they don't have that need.
They can chill.
They can relax their way.
Easier to be around.
Yeah.
Like I've never seen shit start up
between like maybe Brazilian dudes have.
Maybe some Brazilian dudes
have jumped each other.
I was watching a video
and Vandelay Silva was in,
it was two fighting in
the dressing room in La.
[inaudible] silver and
Charles Crazy Horse Bryant.
No,
no,
no.
It was,
it was two of the guys in like Vander,
they was culinary and one of them.
Oh yeah,
that was Cristiana
Marcello and in a triangle.
Yeah,
he got them a try and
I'll put them to sleep.
And that was,
but it was Charles Crazy horse.
Brian and crazy horse actually got up.
The legend is and sucker punched
Vandelay and knocked him out cold.
And it was right before Vandelay was
supposed to fight Ricardo Arona and
Vandelay literally got knocked out,
got woke up and that sent out to this
is if you're going to believe Charles
Crazy Yours Brian,
which I wonder if he's
telling the truth man,
cause you crazy horse was nuts and
he could knock a motherfucker out.
He had a serious punch.
Crazy horse could punch fucking hard
enough to easily knock on 185 pounds if he
sucker punched him.
Did you ever see that fight where he
told that stuffed bear apart in the
columns?
Well he would get to the top of the cage
and do back flips off the top of the
cage.
He was like the first dude doing that.
Sit on the top.
Sit on the uh,
the colon or post.
Yeah,
just jump up and sit up
there during the fight.
He would sucker punch guys like in the
middle of around just wham and that in
and just knock them out.
Call.
It would be like a punch that you don't
think should land had filled a goatee.
Yeah.
Balaclava what he's doing.
These interviews deprive him of that.
But when he was fighting machine mine,
he was calling him
mishy mash up like this,
these eyes.
So it was the fighter that while the,
uh,
the referees reading the instructions,
he's like mugging to the camera
with his big giant smell,
the gold teeth.
He was,
he was another character
right out of a fucking movie.
Yeah.
He was constantly getting
arrested constantly.
I hung out with that dude.
Me and him and Eddie Bravo hung
out with him and his girlfriend.
We watched some fights together.
Um,
it was when,
uh,
k one did an event in,
think it was k one did an
event in Hollywood and a it,
it's some soccer stadium,
some outdoor stadium.
And just by chance we sat
right next to each other.
I had a great time with that dude.
That dude was hilarious.
We were just laughing
at everything he was.
He's,
he's a wild motherfucker.
It's Kinda cool sometimes when you get
get exposed to one of those people just
for a few hours.
Like,
yeah,
I had a college like from Hollywood to
Temecula and back with mayhem and it was
like one of the most high speed,
scariest rides.
It haven't been on,
like,
he's like sitting in the driver's seat
with a shirt with like guns all over it
and a big chain with a gun on their
sunglasses on and he's just like speeding.
And every now and then he said he's like,
police track thing will beep.
And they were like hitting the brakes,
swerving in and out and talking
to a hundred miles an hour.
And it's like two hours
from there and it's five,
four hours of that as well as the
training session in the middle.
I was exhausted by the time I
got really lucky to be alive.
I needed like three days.
I hung out with clay.
Guido,
what weekend in Chicago.
Then he took me to my show.
He insisted on taking me to my show.
So it was,
uh,
me and him and Eddie Bravo and a clay.
Guido was dry.
He Clay Guinta drives like light.
He fights.
He drives exactly like he fights,
but just sitting there just going,
whoa.
Like I trust him.
I think he knows what he's doing.
Oh,
Sam Aaa.
I just got back from driving with him.
You let Sam dry is the scariest man.
He's just like sideswiping swiping cars
while texting and talking on the phone.
I let them text and drive.
He just,
he was just out of control.
It's so funny,
man.
I was scared out of my mind.
That's bad man and now and I gave him
my car to drive up to San Francisco.
I was like,
I didn't know how bad it was and
then when I was up there I was like,
oh shit,
he has to drive home.
And I was like,
oh please Tony,
just please drive most of the time.
And so they drove your car up.
In fact,
God damn,
that's a long ride.
How much is a southwest flight?
Took a hundred bucks.
Cheap.
Fuck hot.
No,
it was like I had this,
I spent like $500 round trip for,
for going up there for some reason.
I don't know if it was because of
that Cinco de Mayo or whatever.
Probably.
Right.
They Jack up rates.
Southwest doesn't go
direct to a San Francisco.
They don't know.
Isn't that weird?
Yeah,
that's crazy Nigga.
I know they go to San Jose.
Yeah,
that's not far from San Francisco.
You could do San Jose and then
he'd drive for like 30 minutes.
What was going to do Oakland,
but you have to take that stupid
thing underneath the ocean.
I was like,
don't do it.
You've already scared me enough to,
it never did at the bar.
Have you ever done the
Bart in San Francisco?
We were filming fear factor in Oakland
and I ate a pot cookie or something and
my hotel room because I was hanging out
with the crew and they were really cool
guys.
But you know,
I was,
I was like,
I have this cookie and let me just say
would probably make it more interesting
hanging out with these.
So I take this,
uh,
it's not an insult.
They were,
but they were straight.
It's my point.
Wouldn't say,
Hey,
who wants some pot cookies?
You'd be like,
oh,
hold on me.
Oh No,
no,
you're not gonna get me that.
You know what?
Are you crazy?
I don't think so.
Powell.
Oh,
you meant straight late.
They don't drink drugs.
They don't fuck around.
Were strict.
No.
Yeah.
I was like,
well it couldn't have
good success with them.
No,
they were straight straight arrows.
Like you could offer them a drink.
I'll have a margarita.
I know they get crazy.
I'll have a Margarita,
but if you like,
who wants to eat some hash
fucking get the fuck away from me.
So eight this pot cooking
and I get on this bar thing,
man,
I am flying.
I just totally over modulated.
Sometimes you just,
you don't know what
the fuck you're eating.
Just eat one and it just puts you,
it puts you in almost
like in another dimension.
It's like you like your
face is under a waterfall,
like about to peer to the other side.
Just can't quite get there like
that high and my ears are ringing.
I'm like more pop and I'm like,
why am I even popping?
And they go,
because we're 500 feet under water.
I was like,
what the fuck he talking about?
Never said yes to this.
If you asked me do you want to
go in a fucking that's under the
ocean in a place where the ground moves,
I would have said,
fuck you.
I don't want to do that.
Why are we doing that?
That's like playing musical chairs.
You know?
I can catch a train from
my apartment in Nottingham.
I found this out through the day.
I've been telling everybody and catch a
train from my apartment in Nottingham to
Saigon.
What?
Right.
How is that possible?
Exactly.
The problem is the only
part of the journey I would
struggle with is the channel
tunnel.
It's
like apparently apparently one train has
to stop while the other one goes past
because the pressure would just
go under the ocean under the ocean.
The fuck with that shit.
That is a movie waiting to happen.
They will tell your story for many,
many years in the future.
Get the fuck Outta here.
It was like a titanic kind of
movie into fuck that movie.
That movie sucks.
You do not want to be in that movie.
You don't want to be dude in
tunnels of concrete under seawater.
Just seeing the rocks
tumbling towards you.
Enormous rocks with walls
of water behind them,
pushing them rocks at
her thousands of pounds.
And it's a matter of 10 15 seconds for
the hit in that circumstance as well.
You're so insignificant.
You don't matter bitch.
You are a footnote in
history and that's a wrap.
Son cleaned her up.
You're clear.
Mr. Hardy.
Thank you for playing this life and
that's why I didn't go to that airport.
Good move.
Now that you put it that way,
can we,
can I,
can I bring up with
that funny thing I saw?
No,
no,
because I'll get mad.
It's unfortunately,
it's so funny.
Um,
Dan Hardee you a,
you recently went to the jungle.
I did in the jungle.
You recently had an experience
in the spirit world.
I did.
That sounds,
doesn't that sound rig a
ridiculous thing to say?
You sound like one of those be wearing
fucking Birkenstock wearing assholes.
Like if you say something like that,
like,
yeah,
I went to spirit world.
Oh yeah,
you did you,
you fuck,
I do yoga like five times a week now.
I'm really not helping.
How
are you willing to go?
The beads,
the beads.
This is like a certain thing too.
It's like,
it sucks when someone's faking that.
Yeah,
no,
yeah,
but oh,
just bend some white sage and the better,
it's like,
you know,
I,
you can see those people from a mile away.
Oh No.
It got great praise on older women.
Yeah.
He's got this older woman and she's
quite a bit older than him and less
attractive to him,
but he's young and fairly useless and
like this fake guru type character.
And you know,
there's a documentary,
I can't what it's called.
It's on Netflix and it's
a guy who he goes out to.
Have you seen it?
Goes out to it?
Oh No,
I haven't seen it,
but I've,
I've heard about to watch it.
He makes a fake religion fake gurry yeah.
Yeah.
If it becomes a fake girl,
let's see,
document around fake group.
Uh,
Netflix just poured that plug
in like 2000 live movies.
They just did.
They really,
cause they lost contracts with,
I think it was a Warner
brothers or something.
But like South Park's gone,
like a lot of shit was gone from it.
Right now Kumar is a true film about a
false prophet with a watch is kind of
interesting.
It's fucked.
How easy it is to trick people.
That's unfortunate.
You know,
people want,
you know why I think this is why I
think it's because it's an insanely rare
quality to be truly enlightened or
even truly on the path of enlightened,
which a true path of enlightenment
with true focus and you know,
and and on a path for a real,
the pure sake of trying to
figure out what this life is,
figuring out how to live this life better.
There's so few people really,
really doing that.
That to even like attempt
to do it is so douchey.
Ish.
It's intimidating to
think for yourself though.
And that's where a lot of people fall.
You know,
it's,
it's scary to think for yourself.
So they want somebody
else to do it for them.
It is,
but it's also,
we don't like people proclaiming that
there is something more grand than the
rest of us.
Yeah.
Some people we don't like people
proclaiming that they're on the path to
figuring out where you're screaming in
your car at a red light and you can't
balance a checkbook and you know,
you know what I mean?
People don't want to believe that there's
a guy who really does do yoga every
day and really does like find his center
and it's made him a more joyous person.
Sad that that is what I hear from you.
A lot of you talking about you buddy.
That's what I hear a lot of you
being impressed with yourself.
A lot of your fucking annoying with
your flip flops and that that's what
happens.
It's like there's so many of those guys,
there's so many,
but it's,
I had this doctor a mic go swami in
here once a theoretical physicist guy,
genius guy and he was saying
that sometimes people have
to fake things in order
to really truly make them happen.
Like,
like I let people,
he's like,
I let people use the word quantum when
I know they don't really know what it
means.
But he's like,
but if this guy like has
interest in like faking it,
like maybe it would lead to a real
interest in trying to understand quantum
science.
And I was like,
wow,
that's a fucking interesting
way to look at it and say like,
so I go,
so like false gurus and play go
say just to let them fake it.
Which I guess,
yeah,
I guess,
but you know,
then they start,
you know,
fucking everybody's wives and well yeah,
yeah.
Kill all the male babies.
You know,
it always go south always.
And it's always a maligned and shit.
His had been a woman run ever.
Can you tell me that there's a fucking,
just that alone is great evidence that
women are way less dangerous than men.
Yeah,
they did.
They have less of a desire
to control the environment.
Yeah.
Even if you have a
shitty woman boss Shane,
no cult leader,
not the closest woman called leader.
She's the closest to a woman
caught later cause she kind of is.
Yeah.
She's kind of running a call.
She's running a cult of happiness amongst
women over 35 Chardonnay called spark.
Make all,
yeah.
Yeah.
She's,
that's her.
Her Shit.
I guess she could run a cult,
you know,
but like there's not a lot of women who
could pull that off and run a call and
what the world looks like
from her perspective,
from Oprah's perspective,
it's gotta be insanity is first of all,
how many women have ever
achieved that before?
How many,
it's not like you're a man.
If you're a man and
you're like a media mogul,
it's like,
oh look another one,
another Richard Branson,
another this,
another,
that,
that guy.
This guy is always a new
guy is always some new guys.
Big Loud mouth is on TV all the time.
It makes a lot of money.
There's always that guy.
Yeah.
Well how many of those girls,
how many girls have just had all these
women screaming and cheering whether they
see her,
she gives away cars and shit.
Saves people in Africa.
How many girls?
What does,
is there one other one ever?
The Angelina Jo leads kind of like
rocking it in some sort of weird way,
but she doesn't have like a talk show,
but she's talking every day.
She's like,
can't control.
That's like you can give people
instructions and they'll follow it.
Go and buy this and millions of
women will go out and buy it.
That's scary power.
Yeah.
Oprah powers.
Weird power.
That's,
it's very rare that a
human achieves that bit,
but she can't,
she has to sacrifice like real
relationships with people we like.
You can't have a real connection
with anybody or you can't develop new
connections when you get
to that kind of status.
I don't think so.
I wonder if you don't let anybody in.
I don't know.
Well,
the only reason you wouldn't is if you
think that you're better than other
people because you're successful.
The,
the,
the issue of running into people that
have wanted to take advantage of you,
you're going to have that
no matter what you know,
you would hope that your filter is
good enough that you'd be able to,
but when it gets to this stage,
you can't go anywhere without
someone recognizing your,
like everybody knows who you are.
Yeah.
You fucked up son.
You took it too deep.
Should've backed off Elvis
to stay alive longer.
Never go full retail.
Yeah.
There's something that happens to people
when they get that cuckoo Fayez you
know,
they get that over the top.
I just didn't vivas
young man's gone.
You can text him,
man.
He tried to take,
uh,
a monkey to Germany to the day.
Like what the fuck is that?
That's what you do when you're fucking
17 years old and he fucked a million
girls a day for the past year
and you look like you're four and he's
a little being unreasonable because they
wanted to take his monkey out.
They are unreasonable.
He's Justin motherfucking Bieber,
Justin Bieber.
He could go to a restaurant and like
put his hands and say hello everybody.
And they would start sharing
and just start clapping.
Twerp Justin Bieber's here,
swag.
They would go,
oh my God.
He just said Swag.
What's,
but that's his thing.
So swag all the time.
How do you know that?
I know a lot that
we've talked about it in the podcast.
You fucking stoner hag.
Yes.
You don't pay attention and things
like that that you blacked me out.
Like I'm looking old marriage.
You blocked me out like we're married.
He,
um,
yeah,
he,
he's um,
I know a dude who,
uh,
has done work for,
Mr Beaver.
He said it's a very nice guy.
Nice kid.
I met his dad too.
I met him and his dad at a UFC fight.
Let him like very briefly,
we had headphones on.
They,
they shook our hands.
Hi.
How are you doing?
And then the fight was going on,
but uh,
no one could ask anyone to be able to
handle that situation any better than that
kid's doing.
He's doing okay.
Way better than I would do.
Could you imagine what fucking damage
you would have done that famous?
It's 17 that must be ridiculous.
I did enough time to get 17 and I was
just,
what kind of life is that?
That's that guy lives.
He,
there's only one person on the planet
that lives like that.
That's him.
Like who is he going
to compare notes with?
I don't know who's going
to understand his life.
Like Britney Spears was that
kind of level at one point.
You know what happened to her?
She went crazy.
She blew a fuse.
I'm kind of excited for it just to be
with sort of to lose his mind as well,
but it's just how is it going to happen,
you know?
Is he going to stop by and
like wild animals and fill
this house with them or to
money in the bank?
I used to do it.
Yeah.
Joke about before Macaulay
Culkin went crazy.
I used to do a joke about
how he's money in the bank.
It's like he,
this ain't gonna won't
turn out well this is you.
You're not always going to be that guy.
You're going to be like
a man someday is gonna
be weird.
Like you,
you became a,
you,
you became unbelievably
famous while you were a child.
How could you possibly handle that
hanging out with Michael Jackson?
Jesus Christ.
You know,
there was a guy who got arrested.
He was like one of those famous,
uh,
Hollywood,
like investigative guys,
like a strong arm investigator.
And uh,
he had done some work with
Michael Jackson and that the war,
what he says is that he wanted to
check in and make sure that all the
molestation allegations were,
were incorrect,
and he said he wouldn't work with Michael
Jackson because he did something worse
than molest them.
What,
what that means know,
I couldn't even imagine
what the fuck that means,
but it was enough spin on things.
It was enough that he wouldn't,
he wouldn't work with a guy.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's true.
I mean,
he's in jail.
The guy who did is in jail
and he did a lot of nefarious,
semi illegal type shit until a strong arm.
Shit,
you know.
But it seems like you had a little bit
of a code and it seems like a whatever
Michael Jackson was
doing according to him,
at least.
That's scary,
man.
We were talking about Cleveland and
we're talking about what happened in
Cleveland before the show starts.
Yeah.
These,
these guys,
these three brothers had kidnapped these
three girls and kept them locked up for
10 years.
So they each got one.
I don't know.
I don't know what they did.
I don't,
I don't know the full
details of the story,
but,
uh,
the guy who,
who saved him as his black dude,
he,
uh,
he said that something happened and I
think you heard some screaming and like he
kicked down a door as
he robbing the place.
No,
no.
We just [inaudible] them.
He's trying to save
them racists little fuck
you G.
I know what you're doing.
I'm just trying to keep black people
from coming to your shows ever.
I know what you're doing.
Noises.
I mean,
I was breaking into their
place and he say he,
um,
he said it was a really interesting thing.
You got to see the interview.
The guys really entertaining
and the guy who saved him pull,
pull up the interview cause
it's pretty fascinating.
And then don't worry folks,
we're still going to talk
about the spirit world.
I know we got off subject but the same,
you know at the Saint,
the Cornell Brian show bitch doesn't,
it doesn't you got requests?
No,
I know people want to hear.
Oh okay.
No they do.
I can't listen to the request.
Like while the show's going on too many
people would just write fucked up shit
and tried to get my attention.
What's that?
That's one.
His name's James Ramsay.
Is that his name?
James Ramsey.
Yeah,
the Charles Ramsey.
Charles Ramsey.
[inaudible] guy's a bad motherfucker.
He saved those girls.
They were in there for 10 years.
These guys were holding
them captive for 10 years.
Like what the fuck happens to people that
allows them to do something like that?
I Dunno.
Like w w is what is
their view of the world?
Like how,
how do they see their own actions?
How did they get to be that thing?
Yeah.
How did they,
that's the real question.
What,
who did something to them,
they must have,
they must have peace with it in some way.
10 years,
a long time.
So have second thoughts,
you know.
Oh yeah.
I mean I don't think,
I think they were just,
that was,
they own them,
that they were going to keep it that way.
But how do you come to the
conclusion that that's okay?
I don't know.
I couldn't imagine
I have this conversation with,
with the people about Michael Vick.
You know,
I'm always kind of vocal about that
and that situation with the dog.
Yes.
Dude.
Here's the dude.
Huh?
How?
Pause it for a second.
Cause I want to,
I want you to hear what you said.
I have to say about this cause yeah,
I,
that disturbs the shit out of me too.
They had the Michael Vick.
Yeah.
I mean it's like I went,
I was up in,
uh,
Utah a couple of weeks ago for
the victory Doug's reunion,
which is basically the,
the dogs that were,
were saved.
I think they took 58.
Uh,
some of them were euthanized
because they were too bad.
Um,
but most of them were taken to a place
called the best friends animal sanctuary.
And uh,
some of them will stay there
for the rest of their lives
because they can't be with
other dogs and you know,
right.
Yeah.
Like the grand champions and stuff,
they all scarred up and stuff,
but a lot of them got,
uh,
got adopted and all the family
stay quite close and they,
you know,
they bring the dogs together
so they can socialize.
But you know,
like some of these dogs that got
chemical burns on their back,
there's one little dog that walks sideways
because it was thrown against a wall
as a puppy.
Like,
like how,
how do you get to the stage where you
think that that's an all right thing to
do?
Like that's,
that's not,
you don't get better from that.
And that's not something that you're,
now he's got another dog,
like he showed up in a pet
smart or the day without this,
it's like some kind of military dog.
He shouldn't have been that it was
anything right with the world that Doug's
going to go for his throat at some point.
Was He allowed to have dogs?
Ridiculous.
All the dogs he killed.
But you don't,
you don't heal from something like that.
That's something that,
that's just something that's,
that's who you are.
Well,
I don't,
I don't think,
what is the story that he
killed a bunch of them,
right?
Yeah.
To be killed.
Them throwing them on the floor.
Electrocuting them hanging them.
Yeah,
he did like torture is shit.
Yeah.
He,
he had a bad reputation in
the dog fight and community.
I mean,
God like 58 dogs yet.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
He had a bad reputation and
the dog fighting community,
you know,
your con when the dog
fighting world is like,
Hey,
I need to sell the fuck down.
You're being mean.
Yeah.
That's some,
that's an,
that's a whole new level of mean.
Holy Shit.
I have a,
I have a friend who
adopted one of his dogs.
Um,
this little dog,
when you take into a room,
it will go and sit in
the corner and shake.
Oh God.
And it just,
you can't go near it without
it just shaking uncontrollably.
And that was a,
yeah,
I think they call them bait dogs.
We're basically a muzzle on the dog and
use it as like a confidence builder for
the,
the fight in dogs.
They're successful.
Oh God.
So it,
but the size of the dog that they bullied.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
But this guy has got another dog now
and he's back playing football and
everyone's called because
he's an athlete and you know,
that's not,
that's not a normal human being.
That's not,
you know,
I,
I agree.
It's not a regular calculation to make.
Well,
it's also,
it's when do you forgive?
There's certain things
that we don't forgive.
Right.
I mean,
we don't forgive Charlamagne's thing.
No one forgets that when,
when a person wants to rape kids,
like you're off the menu for civilization.
Pretty much universal.
Yeah.
But when you,
when you look at what some
people are willing to accept,
when it's clearly that's,
there's like a sociopathic
characteristic to that.
There's,
there's a cruelty characteristic.
But can a guy I learned
from that we know we don't,
they can't learn from childbirth.
They can't,
there's the recidivism
rate is way too high.
Whatever it is.
It's way too sick.
The danger that they
pose is way too great.
It's like there's too much at stake.
But the idea is like a guy that used
to treat dogs like their shit and kill
them.
Should we give that guy a second chance?
But the thing is I don't think he can
change his opinion on his actions.
All I can,
all I can think you can do is realize
that other people don't
find that acceptable.
Well yeah,
there's that.
But there's also that he,
um,
his culture,
like he grew up,
like when he,
from the time he was a little boy,
like they had dog fights.
Like there's a lot of people in this
world today that's still engage in like
really regular dogfights.
Yeah.
And if you are unlucky enough
to be born in that environment,
when do you make your
own moral distinction?
Like when do you realize that
this is a terrible thing?
But even so there's dog
fighting and Doug fine.
I mean like if you read,
uh,
Psalm Sheridan's book,
fights is heart.
There's a bit about dog
fighting in there and they say,
I mean,
I don't agree with it,
but it's a very,
very different perspective.
You know,
that care for the dogs,
they look after them,
they buy them the best food and you know,
really take care of them.
And the dogs fight for fairness,
you know?
Right.
Which I mean,
it's still a kind of
an unusual perspective,
but,
but the stuff that Vic
was doing was just evil,
evil,
which is a whole new level entirely.
And that's the kind of stuff that you,
that you can't,
you can't heal from either thing.
That's,
that's the person that he is.
I met him once and I
didn't know who he was.
I met him backstage.
I'm glad I went.
I don't meet him now because I don't,
I don't know that I'd want
to be anywhere near him.
I,
it just,
you know,
how'd you feel when you met him?
I didn't know who he was.
He's just,
yeah.
When my friend confronted him
about what he'd done to the dogs,
he said he was hoping for some kind of
like aggressive reaction like he was
going,
he was hoping that the guy,
that the guy was at least going
to have a feeling about it.
He said,
but when,
whatever he was telling the guy,
whatever he was talking
to Michael Vick about,
Vic was just like,
just,
just not,
not,
they're just not present,
you know,
he's just,
it didn't understand what was going on.
Not a very smart guy.
Just,
you know.
Have you seen the Charles
Ramsey nine one one call?
I heard.
That's just terrifying.
Somebody just sent it to me with captions.
Yeah,
sure.
Throw it up.
What you're about to hear is e nine one
one call placed by hero Charles Ramsey
after he found a man to marry a woman
who had been kidnapped for the past
decade.
This man saved her life.
5:52 PM 34 seconds.
May Six two zero one
Cleveland mellow one police,
ambulance or fire,
Bro.
I'm 73 more with,
hey,
check this out.
I just came from Mcdonald's,
right?
No,
my mom for cheating my little food.
Right.
It's trying to work out the fucking house.
Next door to me is,
look what the people on
the street right now.
What's the problem?
She like get that me and my daughter
and we've been in this bitch.
She said her name was
Linda Berry or some shit.
I don't know who the fuck that is.
I just moved over here,
Bro.
Calm down this road.
Other
than the street Seymour Avenue.
Is she still in the street
or where did she go?
I'm looking at it.
See Right now she calling y'all see
on another phone and is she black,
white or Hispanic?
She wiped with the baby looking.
Scanning.
Okay.
What is she wearing?
A white tank top like blue,
uh,
flipping it sound like,
like,
like a wife beater.
Did you know the address next door does?
She says she was in here.
I'm looking at it.
Okay.
I thought that was your address.
So that Damn Bro,
I'm telling you.
[inaudible]
sorry mate.
Why?
What's the phone number?
Okay.
Does any justice in the world?
This guy becomes fucking huge
and Kim Kardashians and I'm sure
this is real.
Can you ask her,
this is a real guy.
We'll send the police out.
That guy's a bad motherfucker.
I got to get him on the podcast.
It's like,
yeah we do.
President is amazing.
That's a real man.
So he was breaking into that place.
I was coming from it and there
was somebody trying to break out
of the house like we should
like punching through a window
or I don't know.
So she climbed out somehow somehow
or another she got out of whatever.
They had a locked her up and wow.
Crazy shit man.
10 fucking years and thinking that's
going to be the rest of your life having
these guys just fuck you.
Hold you down to fuck you every
night and feed you fucking oatmeal.
Oh,
some rundown house in Cleveland.
You're a sex slave for
the rest of your life.
You do with those guys.
Kill him.
You got to kill him.
They just got to remove
them from the gene pool.
But,
but then you think there's something,
kind of send a story about
like laying Suni down on the,
on a,
on a bed and injecting
them into light light.
Put them,
put them down.
I don't think it's necessarily,
I think you just dig a hole,
shoot him in the head,
push him in the hole.
I really don't think you need to
be fucking with all this injection.
So clinically it makes it scary,
but that's what they're trying to do,
but they're trying to do is take the uh,
the chaos out of murder.
Yeah.
They're trying to take
all the variables out.
Let's can do a nice
and easy little poison.
Hey,
go.
Hey Dad,
goodbye.
Take care.
That's it.
That's a wrap.
Instead of just shooting someone,
you know,
I mean,
did you ever see that
movie dead man walking?
No.
Sean Penn's a bad motherfucker.
I mean that,
that guy knows how to act as ass off.
He's a crazy dude,
but he knows how to act as his ass off.
And he played this guy that was dying.
He's going,
going in for lethal injection.
And the way he played it was so real.
Like you really thought
he was gonna fucking die.
And that's all avoidable man.
All that craziness.
A strapping that guy and it freaking them
out and injecting him so that you can
feel better.
Just shoot him and the fact and
head and let's be done with this.
Okay.
It's real simple.
That's a bad person.
He's broken.
We got to get rid of them.
Shoot them.
Okay.
There we go.
Like they do on the walking dead.
I think they should be put them in
a trough first at like a Skinner,
the concert and we all get to like
piss on them for it or something,
you
know,
like something cool like that first.
That's not cool.
That's just weird.
Yeah,
it was pissed off.
Hey,
what do you want to do today?
So I'm cool.
It's beside each other.
So tell me about your
journey in the jungle.
Okay.
What was the,
was that all about?
What happened?
What caused you to want to do this?
I don't really know.
I just felt,
I felt like I was drawn to it.
Um,
I was,
I was speaking to a friend of mine,
I won't mention him,
but he's under the fighter.
I'm retired now.
Uh,
and,
and he did a couple of
ceremonies in London,
a friend's place.
They brought a sham it over and,
uh,
did a couple of,
and I've always been kind of the guy
that if I wanted to experience something,
I would go to the source.
You know what I mean?
I would like,
like if I wanted to do kung feel,
I go to China and if I want to rest,
I come to America and you know,
if I want to try Ios guy I go to Peru.
It just kind of made sense.
So,
um,
it was kind of like my reward
for getting through the Catlin,
the Duane Ludwig camp,
because that was obviously,
you know,
that would have been a loss in a row
and obviously a complete changing career
paths.
Um,
so I just kind of,
you know,
I put 12 weeks aside to
dedicate myself to that fight.
And you know,
with that as a,
as a reward after in a couple
of days after the fight,
I flew out and spent two weeks there,
did a tobacco ceremony on the first day
three Ios because ceremonies and to San
Pedro ceremonies,
how's that tea ceremony?
They basically make a drink of uh,
tobacco,
coffee and sugar and they cook it up and
then you drink a whole load of it and
it's like a purge,
like a detox.
Like if you've got any kind
of toxins in your system,
you throw up when you sweat and some
people will crying and obviously there's
all kinds of other nasty
stuff that goes on as well.
But,
um,
it's just,
it's,
it's a way of like cleansing your body
before the Ios go theoretical cleansing
or does it actually
have a cleansing effect?
It's got a client,
fortunately had been in,
in training camp for 12 weeks,
so I'd been on a clean diet and I just,
I just kept my diet clean until I've,
I've got to Peru because
there's a special diet for,
for the ios because it's a low,
a acidic diet,
right?
Sugar,
no oils,
no sex,
no spices,
oils,
oils.
I don't know.
I,
it's interesting.
Yeah,
there are a lot of things,
a lot of things on the list that I'm
Kinda on the fence about and it's kind of,
it's weird because there's not
really any kind of science behind it.
I mean,
there are some things that you can't
have because they react badly with the,
with,
with the medicine.
But,
uh,
some of the foods are kind of kind of odd.
I just kind of go on instinct when I'm,
when I'm dieting for it right now.
So the tobacco ceremony,
there's no psychoactive effect,
no nothing.
It's just like,
it's just like smoking three packets of
cigarettes and drinking six Starbucks
all at the same time.
It sounds like the future of Syria.
I don't drink coffee.
I don't drink caffeine or
obviously smoke cigarettes.
So I'm like,
I'm like sitting in my room
like shaking and sweating.
It was kind of uncomfortable.
But once that was over,
the next day was,
was the first ios because homeowner and
I did feel real sharp the next morning.
I felt very,
very alone.
Okay.
So the next morning you
do the ILS get ceremony.
What was that like?
Uh,
well you don't need a great deal of during
the day we had a light breakfast and
then,
uh,
you know,
like a,
like a fruit snack around mid day and
then after that you fast and the ceremony
starts to 8:00 PM.
Um,
so the idea is that you go into
the ceremony with intentions,
that things that you wanted,
uh,
question questions you want to ask.
Um,
there's,
there's always this talk about,
uh,
about,
ios because the spirit of Ios,
Sca,
mother I Alaska and some people during
their experiences have an interaction
with a female entity of some
point that was of some sort,
but I didn't,
but uh,
but the intentions are
still very important.
Going into the ceremony with,
uh,
you know,
with questions about myself
or my life or whatever,
really for me,
the answer's just Kinda
just kinda manifested.
It just kind of show up.
I just kind of all of a sudden
getting an overwhelming feeling of,
of,
of the right,
the right answer.
I don't really know how to
explain it better than that.
It's kind of the problem is
that I really feel like we've,
we've not got the language to explain
this kind of stuff at the moment.
We need,
we need to expand it,
our vocabulary to,
to encompass all the,
you know,
all the stuff that we were
experiencing these things.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people believe
that what a psychedelic states,
even if they don't believe in that you're
really contacting the spirit world,
what they think you're doing
by forcing yourself to,
to take a hard look at yourself and,
uh,
address some questions that you
might have one way or another.
But to do it with this stuff
that absorb it absolves your ego.
It removes the ego.
And in doing that,
it's a rare state that you get to
get the fuck away from your ego,
but it really lets you get away from it
to a point where you can see things so
much more clearly.
Yeah.
And you can realize how much of the
ego is just been really been sort of
tricking you and deceiving you and
making you believe that you're,
you know,
you're either something that you're not,
or you've gone further than
you really actually have,
or your ego is allowed you to
sort of delude yourself to,
to get by.
That's very strenuous existence.
And when you go into a psychedelic state,
it allows you to bypass
all that and see it.
And it doesn't,
you know,
that that's where like,
people don't understand that you can
get to a mild psychedelic state from
exercise and yoga.
Yeah.
I mean,
fasting,
yeah.
Meditation and yeah,
you can get there just to
sensory deprivation tanks.
You can get to a pretty extreme
form with no drugs at all.
But the IOWASCA ceremony is basically
known as prior the grand mall of a,
of the psychedelic experiences,
the most spiritual of the
psychedelic experiences.
Yeah.
It's pretty powerful in comparison to
other things after I've experienced this.
Have you ever experienced the,
the
raw form of DMT?
Yeah.
Only once though.
Was it five Meo DMT or was it an DMT?
Uh,
there's two different kinds.
One,
okay.
Five meo yeah,
five Erminio is quite a bit different.
Yeah,
it's a,
there's no visuals.
It's a very intense feeling
of connection and it's very,
very potent.
In fact,
I think it's like supposedly,
obviously I'm not some
sort of a scientist here,
but a,
supposedly it's even more powerful
gram per gram than DMT is.
But the DMT,
the NMD,
mts,
what you're getting in the IOWASCA.
Okay.
When you eat it,
if you tried to eat DMT,
there's a stomach,
uh,
chemical produced your,
your,
your chemical,
your stomach produces something
called Mano aimeen oxidase apparently.
And that breaks down DMT.
So with these brilliant people that live
in the Amazon and figured out how to do
it was mixed the vine of one plant with
the leaves of another and cook it all
together.
So they introduced a natural Mao
inhibitor that not blow your mind.
It's insane.
Plays in mind.
Did you ask them how they figured it
out and not Terence Mckenna did and he,
he said that they always said
that the plants how to do it.
But you know,
I've always thought about this with diet,
like,
like people who have been combining
like incomplete proteins for years,
like milk and cereal and
rice and beans and not,
not knowing that those,
those two things combined
made a complete protein.
So why would they combine them?
Yeah,
it's funny,
right?
I mean it's like,
it's nice.
It's like an odd coincidence.
But I will ask is like the same
thing but a way more extreme.
Well,
there's a lot of folks
bully,
I shouldn't say a lot of folks,
but it's been speculated.
I've read,
uh,
read work where people believe that
what we've created with civilization and
with societies and uh,
especially with like modern
societies where there's like mass,
uh,
speed communication.
It's like people are sending each other
text messages and watching television,
all these is that we're missing out key
information that is there in nature.
And that literally,
if you're in a natural state,
like if you're living in a natural
state and you're away from the,
the,
the distractions and the madness
of the fucking civilized world,
that there's literally a signal that
you can't quite pick up anymore.
And that signal is like a guide to get
through life at like the earth literally
does talk to.
Is that the collective consciousness,
do you think?
I Dunno.
I mean,
I don't know if I believe that it ever
really was the kid of the case that
people were much more sensitive
to the language of the earth.
It is possible.
I think it's really hard to even wrap our
heads around what it must've been like
before they were lying,
which I know all the toxins that we've,
that we've produced as well.
All the things that we've been to
introduce to our diet until our bodies,
like,
like the dashboard on my truck outside,
he's killing me slowly.
You know what I mean?
That's the kind of stuff.
Yeah,
it's,
you know,
they had met them,
met all kinds of chemicals and you know,
like,
like fluoride is,
as people are now starting to
understand fluoride is bad for you.
Well how many is that?
Yeah.
Calcifies your pineal gland supposedly.
I don't know if there's
ever been any real studies.
I have a feeling that might be
something that someone just said once.
Everybody just repeats.
I can take it out and I don't mind.
Well,
it's,
I don't think there's necessarily a
lot of evidence that it's good for you
think,
uh,
people say that there's a connection
between putting fluoride in the water and
removing tooth decay.
But that also coincided with
education about brushing.
I mean,
the other,
that shit went down when people
realize that you have to brush,
you know,
and then putting fluoride in your teeth,
brush in your toothpaste.
Apparently that's not so good either.
Even though you don't eat it,
it's still,
it's like there's a reason why you
don't swallow that stuff once you like.
She like,
yeah.
Famous in the foam it up in your mind.
Drinking water though.
Yeah.
Fucking it's crazy.
Yeah,
but why do we still do it though?
I don't know.
That's pretty awesome.
So I'm sure that some grants scheme that
send me a tweet about and I'll spend
the next four hours festering over it.
What else?
I think these are things
that are potentially like,
you know,
like keeping as disconnected from,
from this whatever we're missing
out on this language that we're,
that we're missing out on front of the,
maybe it's possible,
but I think that if you were living
in the jungle and you needed,
you know,
you needed to survive there and
it is possible that you would eat,
least have an idea of mixing these
two things together and cooking them.
Yeah,
but you imagine if you
found out you were right,
like when you created Iowasca me,
if the dude just nailed it the first time,
like let's see what we got here.
It takes a sip.
Yeah.
Do,
do,
do doom,
doom,
doom.
He must've been like,
God damn,
did I knock it out of the park?
Well the fuck your vegetable soup.
I got some shit.
It will kick your Dick
right into the dirt sign.
But look at the guy that
found that the discovered LSD.
Yeah.
Albert Hoffman.
Like completely complete accident.
And not only that and he like rode
home and thought he was going mad
bicycle.
First LSD trip ever.
And then didn't you go back a couple of
days later and said like it like five
times the amount or something?
I don't know.
I think the initial amount he took was
way higher than like a normal dose.
It's like a bucket.
I think it came in through
his fingers I think because,
um,
that's the thing about acid,
it'll go right through your skin.
Yeah.
Had that happened.
That's exciting for the first time,
the first dude to figure out
Iowasca how long ago was that?
They'd say it's at least 2000 years.
They say they've,
they've,
they've shown like archeological evidence
of Iowasca use up to 2000 years ago.
How do you even,
I mean,
I can't make sense of it now and I have,
you know,
uh,
much more,
a much better understanding
of the universe and you know,
as,
as obviously it's science knows it,
but like back then when all you know is,
is the jungle and the plants around
you and how would you even begin
to make sense of that?
How would you begin to make sense of that?
Yeah.
How would you,
and then how do you become an expert,
uh,
introducing that to other people,
like a shaman,
which I find really fascinating.
The idea of shamanism.
It's very fascinating.
You know why it's fascinating because
you've experienced it and you know,
it's real to a joke.
Construction worker lunchbox that's
listening to this nonsense right now.
You know,
I like that Joe Rogan podcasts,
but every now and then they go off
the fucking tin foil hat deepened.
And this guy's talking about journey
into the spirit world that I want to be a
Shama and get the fuck outta here.
Tell me a joke.
Ass face.
Okay.
That's what you're here for.
Your fuck.
That guy is a black belt under Matt Serra.
Possibly.
Well done.
Yeah.
The,
um,
the,
you know,
it's real that you've done it,
you've experienced it and it's,
it's not just real,
it's real in a way where you
feel sorry for people who haven't
great first it because if,
but,
but at the same time I,
you know,
when I,
when I first came back from
Peru and people were asking me,
you know,
is this something that
everyone should experience?
I was saying yes to everybody
but now I'm not so sure.
I think there are like I was walking
through the looks side of the day and you
know,
God bless America and all the people
that were pumping money into those slots
and smoking cigarettes and drinking beers,
but they need a lot of,
they need to a lot of self
discovery without an altered
state before there would
be even ready for that.
Like if you took them
and gave him my Alaska,
it would ruin them forever.
Maybe,
maybe this,
you know,
maybe just seeing them at their worst.
Maybe they would say that about
you if they caught you beaten off.
Well maybe you know,
you're there and your I's
cross your tongue out and like,
yeah,
this guy really needs a fucking,
I lost this seminar.
You need to get your own life together,
son.
Yeah they would,
they would come down on you.
But it's Kinda,
it's Kinda weird because like the
people that find their way to it a light
already in a place in their life
where they're kind of prepared for it,
you know,
that that happens a lot of the time.
But I'm not completely convinced
that happens all the time.
I've definitely heard of people having
bad experiences or going there when they
weren't ready for it.
Yeah.
I think psychedelic experiences
are incredibly powerful.
And to say that people should or shouldn't
do it is equally foolish because to
say that someone should do it,
it's like,
how the fuck do you know
that guy should do at what?
Cause you did it and you like it.
Yeah,
I agree with that.
I just think,
you know,
it's just,
it's a lot to process for
someone that's open minded.
Right.
So for someone that is buying
into the Oprah call and you know,
hope it's bad ass,
dude,
don't get me wrong,
don't get it twisted.
[inaudible] I'd like to take over to Peru.
We need to do we need to get
Oprah and bring her to the jungle?
Yeah,
I think this is the way forward.
I think this is how we move to the next
stage of our evolution is we've got to
start getting some of these,
these power people and taking them out
there and I think it's really happening.
We haven't heard about it at all yet.
I hope so.
Listen,
there's,
if there really are people
and they really are,
that really do have a massive amount of
power in this world and they really do
eat,
you don't think that they've
wanted to look into that.
Like why would you not
want to look in that?
If there's anything
that can freak you out.
If you were in the build the Berger Group,
you mother fuckers
sitting around and do it.
Iowasca talking to the the great serpent
as it breaks down your life and the
kind of damage that you're
doing to society and
civilization and how unnecessary
it is and how you're still unhappy,
even though you're doing it,
even though you're manipulating the banks,
controlling the resources of the world,
instigating wars overseas and profiting
off of it and some strange fucking shell
game that nobody completely understands.
You're still not happy bitch.
And that's what it would tell you.
It would be good for everybody.
But what'd you think?
What you think?
If you've got the Bilderberg into us,
Sarah,
into ceremony and I think they all need
to realize that you don't need that much
money at fuck crazy.
You're going crazy asshole.
You got caught up in your own game.
Isn't it?
Got to the point where you're controlling
the world's economy and you're worth
billions.
What are you doing?
You don't need billions.
That's stupid,
man.
That's dumb.
You can have a nice house and food and
not worry about shit for way less and
never have to worry about a single
thing for the rest of your life.
Like you're in some crazy stratosphere
that no one reaches and you're still
trying to make more money.
He's still trying to fuck people over.
You're a sick fuck.
You're sick.
Yeah.
Cause obviously broken the very stupid
too because you could be having a great
fucking time every day
for the rest of your life.
If I had billions of dollars
every day would be fishing.
I would fucking go fly kites.
I would,
I would do traveled to it.
Today we're going to Hawaii.
Who gives a fuck?
You've got $100 million in the
bank like you're in instead.
What are you doing?
You're trying to fuck over Portugal.
You're trying to steal,
steal oil out of the Amazon.
What do,
yeah.
What are you trying to do?
What he tried to your here
fucking cutting up the world.
Yeah.
It's not necessary,
but they don't know any better because
they're caught up just like those same
people at the casino though,
those people are caught up to,
they're caught up in like a hitch and
the human mind that allows you to try to
solve puzzles and seek conclusions and
you're good and you just hijack that shit
with three lemons.
Come on,
get,
fuck.
I could find the three lemons there in
there and then your brain gets locked in
this stupid thing and then the cigarettes,
you're suck on these cigarettes that
these same people extracting millions of
dollars from the society by feeding
people these poisonous fucking,
we'd filled tubes that you light on
fire and you poison yourself and I went
slow.
They give him the drugs to fix it.
Yeah,
lots of play.
I've got plenty of shit to.
I would,
you know,
basically they're not cancer of the
boxes in the next couple of years.
You have to whereby Mr. Johnson
just keep fucking smoking away.
It's a,
we live in a mad world.
We live,
we live in a world that should be a
movie and nowhere is that more readily
available or honest then when you
have a psychedelic experience,
because when you see what mushrooms can
do or we could see what DMT could do and
whether it's an io Wasco
or regular form you,
you s you realize like,
wow,
there really is like a magic in the world.
And it sounds so stupid that
if you haven't experienced it,
you really would.
And even people,
even people who have experienced it,
they don't want to describe it that way
cause you don't want to sound stupid to
people haven't experienced it.
So they'll go,
look,
it's nothing magic.
Your,
your cerebral cortex gets
flooded with chemicals.
You're the visual aspect of your
interpretation of the world around you.
It gets,
hey,
hijacked by these,
uh,
new chemicals and it just fucking give it.
Maybe,
maybe,
or maybe you haven't done it yet.
And if you have done it,
maybe just cynical.
Maybe you're missing out
on what the fuck that is.
That's the magic fairy dust pitch.
You get to go to a fairy land.
But I do find that I can't speak as
openly with people that haven't had that
experience anymore.
Crazy.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I say I say energy a lot
more than they used to.
I say powerful a lot.
Good.
It's a good thing to say.
I have a lot of power days now.
Like sometimes I'll get standard down,
I'd be like,
Yep,
that was a power day.
Like I'll be out in the
valley of fire and you know,
swimming in lake mead
and stuff and it's like,
yeah,
what's your a with,
what's your Kale count per day?
Oh,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
Yeah.
Um,
but thinking that way,
like being powerful and,
and thinking positively,
that really does change your fucking
life and people don't understand that.
Like it is silly.
Yeah.
It definitely seems silly.
It sits.
If you're a serious person who's
a conservative man who's not,
and not to be mocked and laughed at,
he wouldn't engage in
Chester such behaviors,
but life itself is silly.
The whole thing is silly.
The whole thing is completely ridiculous,
you know?
So if he did not to be worried
about looking stupid by trying that,
yeah.
It's the whole,
the whole,
my whole perspective
of life changed though.
I,
I quite liked the temporariness of it now.
Yeah.
Because,
because this is the space
that I always experienced,
you know,
with the Ios Ska and you know,
other psychedelic like DMT or psilocybin.
I always feel like,
like the place,
our reach when I've had the
right kind of amount is,
is a very familiar,
safe place.
I've been there hundreds of times before.
It's like,
oh,
I'm back.
Yeah.
Isn't that the weirdest
thing about it is really odd.
The weirdest thing about it is how
it feels so comfortable and so,
so normal.
It feels so familiar.
Yeah.
I think,
I think woman described it in the,
the DMT,
but the spirit molecule book
a doctor Rick Strassman,
she said,
um,
it feels like a waiting room
between death and birth,
which I thought was kind of
an interesting perspective.
Wow.
I remember my knees,
my latest psychedelic
trip that it was like,
just like that where I'm like,
I've been here before,
why can't I remember this?
Like,
it seems like I do that a lot,
like go to the same place so many times.
Yeah.
Well,
what would be a part of your brain,
right.
It could,
it's,
it's so close to normal
human neuro chemistry.
The most profound ones,
they're all,
they're so close to normal shit
you bring produces like mushrooms,
mushrooms and DMT or like very closely
combined are very closely related to
chemicals and DMT is
produced by your brain.
So all of those experiences are just,
they know exactly where to hit in
your mind to produce this stuff.
Can't think that that's a coincidence.
I can't think that that's all an accident.
No,
I,
I like,
I like Terence Mckenna's theory on,
on the introduction,
this other side of it into the human diet.
Yeah.
When we became,
uh,
you know,
from the canopy dwelling fruity taste
to the plain dwelling kind of forages.
Um,
I don't know if that holds up
scientifically as far as the timeline,
but no,
I've never heard anyone say
anything more plausible.
No,
there's no real serious explanation.
It was a huge leap in consciousness,
a doubling of the human brain size.
We were a period of 2 million years and
apparently that's the greatest mystery
in the entire fossil record.
I've always wanted to,
to have a real light dose of mushrooms
and fight like a grandma or grandma and a
half and fight and fight.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I know people who've played pool
with it and they say they can't miss.
They say they know where
the ball is at all times.
They feel it moving on the table
in three dimensional space.
Wow.
Yeah.
Guys used to play pool on a small amounts
of acid too and like have the best
game of their life.
I mean,
what a waste waste of LSD.
You know,
I guess you'd want to be
doing something creative,
but if you were a series pool player,
like that's apparently the way to
get really awesome series pool.
Plenty.
I played a lot pool.
Yeah.
For Real.
But he's not as a job though.
Like you don't do it like I
would play professionally.
Showback golf though.
I mean,
no,
no.
Golf is first of all golf.
You're out there walking
around in the rain.
That's retarded.
And,
uh,
second of all,
he chasing a ball around pool.
It's all on this one table
that the environment is
exactly the same every time.
You're not dealing with holes and roles.
And I bet I would love golf,
but I'm terrified of trying it and
finding out that I love and predictable.
So much work.
You're out there eight hours a day chasing
a fucking ball and when you play 18
holes,
like that's several
hours worth of playing,
drinking that Joe that's,
did you enjoy it more with LSD?
Bill Murray didn't Cag shot it wasn't
that as thing wasn't it taken acid and
play golf?
It's been so long.
I know that people have done it.
Yeah.
It gives you more sensitivity apparently.
More spacial recognition,
more uh,
understanding of distance deception.
Yeah.
And the depth perception and apparently
in a way that really you'd never,
you never see this field.
Medical scientists and
Silva's secrets every time.
Fights.
Yeah.
Could you imagine if he,
well,
you know,
steroids,
but you tested positive for mushrooms.
You fuck like Jesus.
What are you doing?
Fighting how much it should be a
separate belt for that entirely.
Well,
there was a baseball player,
a famous baseball player who pitched
a no hitter while I was on acid.
Yeah.
Who was that?
Do you know what it is?
Hold on.
I'll pull it up.
No,
hit her on acid.
It was not during the seven days and uh,
apparently what happened was he wasn't
supposed be pitching dock Ellis.
He wasn't supposed to
be pitching that day.
So he's decided to get lit up,
take some acid and then
like something happened.
They called him in and he had to go
play and he said he was just fine.
Heinie pitch a no hitter.
See,
I'd love to have lived through those
days of sport instead of these.
Now these are two regulators,
you know?
Yeah.
Let's go back to those,
the those like 1960s and seventies.
Those were crazy days.
But you can't go back.
No,
they're going to be looking back at this
day thinking how crazy we were as well.
I often think of all the
things that are going to,
we're going to look back on even when I'm,
or when I'm going to
look back and be like,
wow,
we actually did that.
Like,
like I remember I smoked like
people smoking on planes.
Yes,
I remember that.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Like even like I live in Vegas now,
walk into the casino and I'm like,
oh,
there's smoke everywhere.
It's like two years ago that
people stop smoking in the UK.
Oh yeah.
Well I've immediately made
the adjustment though.
So like in,
in like 30 or 40 years time,
like when I'm on a plane and we're like,
you know,
I can't even imagine
what it would be like,
but we're going to look back at
sort of like Delta and be like,
hell no.
I can't believe I ever did that.
I lost my bags.
I was,
I was stuck between two
fat guys sweating on me,
you know?
Yeah.
The definitely,
yeah.
With this kind of be one day.
I'm sure there's going to
be a better version of that,
but the,
the smoking and the sky's
the most ridiculous one.
Or when you like nurses and dentists
could like smoke while they're actually
working on your team.
Fifties movies and shit.
Yeah.
Everyone smoked.
I was watching the invasion of
the body snatchers seal the day,
the old version,
fucking doctors sitting there lighten
up in the middle of a doctor's
appointment.
You're definitely talking too
much about cigarettes today.
I'm the freaking out junkie.
He's hooked.
But yeah.
The,
um,
do you think that,
I mean,
it sounds like a crazy thing to say,
but do you think that
I'm open to the future?
I'm sure you are.
Do you think that the future of the world,
like I
do think that it really depends on how
many people have psychedelic experiences
like that.
We need to tip the numbers in that
direction in order for it to get,
uh,
just a,
a large percentage of people that are
at least willing to question the way the
whole thing is built,
at least willing to question the
way they're living their own lives,
at least willing to question
what it is we're doing here.
What are we doing exactly?
Moving on momentum every day.
Getting up when your alarm clock goes off,
what the fuck are we doing?
But we were running on,
like Terence Mckenna would say,
an operating system and the
one that we're in nones,
prehistoric,
you know,
everyone's trying to control each other.
Everyone's jealous of what
everybody else has gotten.
We really need to get past that.
Realize that I don't need to be jealous.
So what anyone else has got because I'm,
I'm good with what I've got,
you know,
and just kind of,
I dunno,
people are not finding peace,
so they're surround himself with
things that they think make them happy.
We haven't been aware for very long.
No,
I think that's a real problem.
I think that human race is in the middle
of waking up and trying to figure out
what the fuck it did to get here
and what it can do moving forward.
And right now we're still operating
on what it did to get here.
We're still operating on the ripples of
the affects of everything that's gone on
in the past.
And so when you say something like that,
like yeah,
I mean people need to do psychedelics.
They just immediately dismiss you.
Like you're all all this crazy
fuck like listening to him.
Yeah.
People need to do drugs.
That's what they need to do.
Dan Hardee they needed,
but the thing,
the thing is I don't think,
I don't think the focus should be
what it has to be psychedelics.
It's just,
it's just about people
becoming more conscious,
making conscious decisions and you know,
even when it comes to light diet
and an exercise practice and,
and uh,
you know,
just,
just your approach to people into
relationships to how you would,
you deal with people,
your impact on the world and you know,
and as soon as more people
start thinking about that,
then we're going to start moving forward.
I think psychedelics has
just kind of a shortcut,
like,
you know,
it just kind of upgrade
you a little bit quicker,
see things a little clearer.
Like,
like before it,
before my first,
my first ILS Alaska experience,
I always felt like I was
in amongst my issues,
like the worst surrounding me and I
couldn't really see clearly I couldn't get
the pieces in order to put them together.
Right.
And as soon as that
first ceremony was over,
I felt like I could step back and look
at all the pieces in front of me and like
piece things together.
Almost like everything's a game,
you know?
And I think that was it to Tom Campbell
you were talking to a while ago.
There's a video of you and him on,
on Youtube talking.
Um,
and he's,
he's talking about the idea of a gamble.
Yeah.
Thomas Campbell
Soup Guy.
I'm sure that's his name.
It was like a total,
is it about what we were talking about?
Um,
you know,
just the idea.
He's light like the Matrix,
like it's a video game.
Like I,
oh,
I see.
I think they combined.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
And some things,
that's a good video.
Anyway.
That's a very interesting,
oh yeah,
yeah,
that's what it is.
That there's,
there's a lot of people that do these
brilliant kind of animals together.
Yeah.
They do them on their own.
No one,
no one tells him to do it.
They just do it.
And there's so many of them out there.
That's incredible.
But like,
I,
I kind of like,
my approach to life now is,
is,
is almost like a video game.
Like,
like I'm constantly trying to level up.
I'm constantly trying to get to the next,
next stage to try and like,
like forced evolution almost.
Right.
You know,
and I think that like we were
talking about this the day,
um,
swimming in the,
in the lake,
it's smoking weed,
um,
just kind of hanging out and all of a
sudden it all kind of fell into place for
me.
Like there were certain people
that that make an effort to,
to,
to reach,
reach a higher consciousness,
so that,
so imagine them as like,
as like bubbles on the table.
Imagine the tables full of bubbles and
one of those people starts to drift off a
little quicker and that is going to
create a reaction of the people around it.
And then they're going to pull up and
occasionally you're going to get like a
Jim Morrison or a Hendrix or a Martin
Luther King and they just kind of go by
just pop and explode.
But they're cause such a,
such a ripple that they start to
raise everybody else's consciousness.
So I think everybody has a
responsibility to raise their own.
And,
and by doing that,
we're going to,
we're going to affect
the people around us.
That's a g hippie term.
It is.
Raise your consciousness.
It sounds like I am a filthy hip,
but it sounds like what to do.
Let's say if he's trying to fuck you try,
you know,
just trying to raise your consciousness
to that a few and I made love brings us
closer.
Wow,
that does sound like me.
Listen,
Dan Harney,
I know,
I know your tricks on,
um,
but what what you're saying
though I agree with entirely,
even though it sounds
like dirty hippy talk,
what you're saying is that we have to
kind of realize that the only way to
really enjoy this life is you got to not
just bring yourself up but bring up the
people around you.
And as they rise up it
will rise you up as well.
And that we really all connected and
it's your ego that keeps you from seeing
that it's your ego from trying to separate
yourself from all these people that
are around you and sinking,
that you're on your own,
but you're not on your own.
No one's on their own.
No.
And,
and I struggled to come to terms
with some things like the weight,
like Michael Vick,
trees,
animals or like there's a documentary
that's wait a while to go on youtube and I
apologize for anybody that watched it
because it's the most awful thing I've
ever seen.
It's called earthlings
and it's just a video of,
of of the different ways that
humans use and treat animals.
And I got to like 26 minutes
and I had to stop watching it.
It was so difficult and I always struggle
with coming to terms with why that
happens.
Why is that there?
And,
and my conclusion is that is that because
it causes me to have a reaction to
have a feeling about it.
So everybody that sees me,
every witnesses that will immediately
form an opinion and that defines them a
little further to themselves.
W W we have to ask these questions
about how do we feel about that?
That makes me feel uncomfortable.
I don't think that that's necessary
and I don't want to watch that.
Well.
You'd also,
the reason why that exists,
the reason why those things can happen
is that people are willing to overlook
normal human morals and
values in favor of profits.
Yeah.
And when,
as soon as your,
the,
the numbers,
the one in the zero become the almighty,
then you're fucked because then you're
caught up in the wave of ones and Zeros
yourself.
You can become just as disposables,
anybody else.
I mean,
you should just,
that alone should get people
recognize that human humanely,
if you want to like get
through this life humanely,
like you can not only look at the ones
and Zeros because that's everything
that's fucked up about the world.
Whether it's war,
whether it's a manipulation
of the markets,
whether it's controlling and actually all
of it is about ones and zeros percent.
Yeah.
And the people that have,
that have built this,
their society around it,
this operating system
that we function under,
I've of that they've kind of,
they've kind of corralled into a
position where we don't have to these,
these decisions.
We don't have to ask
these questions about,
you know,
it does.
The Hummer that I drive,
drink far too much filled and Hamas
having too much impact on my environment
around me.
Am I an asshole for driving it?
You know what I mean?
It's that kind of people
don't need to ask.
Then you see this as a man who loves
classic cars and it's a love hate
relationship.
I have,
I have my Pontiac's sitting in the garage
and I drive it probably once a month
and I've been talking about it,
about selling it for a while
and you're going to get a Prius,
Dan horny.
I can't,
I can't do it for you.
But the thing is,
the thing that doesn't make any sense,
Shelby gt five hundreds of new ones,
pretty fucking good on gas.
It turns out a big powerful engine
that's not working very hard.
It's pretty efficient.
But the thing is the technology.
Yeah,
just get the dancing bears
around your belly button.
That's why.
But it's like,
like in the UK,
I had to,
I had a kid,
a sponsorship for a while in the UK
and they would give me a new car.
But Tom,
I went back to drive and
it was like what a thrill.
But,
but seriously though,
like it was a 1.6 diesel,
they call it like 60 miles to the gallon.
So,
so why is that technology not making it
over to the u s because it's boring as
fuck to drive.
There's no soul.
You can't listen to Prius.
Leonard Skinner did music,
we drive around in a Kia diesel.
So,
so the options are three
hours that gets full.
It doesn't sound right.
You want to hear the engine,
you want to be able to
shift your own gears,
son,
all these things that are dying off.
I'd be more that.
But then on the flip side,
you know,
should I drive a car
that drinks so much fuel?
So eventually we can,
we can get through this quicker.
And then the people that
have control of the fuel,
you will lose that power and
then we can start thinking ahead,
you know?
And then we need Hamline.
It's Easel to run our muscle cars.
You know,
it's a finite resource.
So maybe we should just get
through it as quickly as possible.
It is a finite resource apparently,
but I don't understand how that works.
I don't understand how much oil is left.
You know the problem with one of those
controversial subjects like peak oil is
when you hear those guys talk,
you don't know who the fuck is wrong.
You know this guy saying,
I read a book called black
gold stranglehold that was
claiming that oil is a re
repeatably made,
repeatedly made fluid and
that wells that have gone dry,
if you give them enough time,
they started producing oil again.
The thing is that the only people that
know the real facts of the people that
are in control anyway,
so why would they tell us the truth?
Yeah,
I don't know.
I mean the idea that
anybody could own the oil.
I mean that's ridiculous.
That's the whole earth.
You fuck me over there?
And your metal boxes getting his con.
But I'll say this about like,
like Red Rock Canyon.
Like I go out there hiking
and I'll get there at like,
you know,
four 50 in the park closes at five.
It's a mountain.
How does it close?
Yeah.
You know what?
That's from there.
They know what they're tired of picking
people's pieces and having people there,
so listen,
you fucks.
You can't be,
can't be out here because it's dangerous.
Too many you dummies get drunk
and fall off cliffs and die.
That's why I think those dummies should
get drunk and fall off cliffs and die.
That's the way a thin in the hood without
is actually going out and shooting
people.
You son,
you know there was a,
there was a woman who recently died like
this this week in France and she fell
from like 900 feet off the top of a cliff.
By the time they got down to her,
the vultures had already eaten her.
Oh well that saves carrying a back.
Yes.
That's one way to look at it.
Let's just take all of light.
You know,
all of the safety precautions that we,
I'm like fences around like
moving parts and like crossings.
If you can't make it across the
street without getting hit by a car.
Another thing as well.
And I have a lot of people that disagreed
with me when I spoke about this on
Twitter,
50 mile an hour zones around schools.
Like if,
if,
if all the time when
when I went I was a kid,
I grew up around cause move
moving at 50 miles an hour,
why would I ever take them
seriously as a threat?
Like,
like we need to do things because
these things are fucking dangerous.
Yeah,
that's totally true.
So we need to,
we need to learn to be careful about it,
but it's all about education.
Yes,
I agree with you.
But to play devil's advocate,
there's too many dumb cunts out there
that need a sign that it gives them an
unreasonable speed limits.
Just say slow the fuck down
when they were around schools,
like our friends that we're
talking about speeding and texting,
you can't have a 60 mile an hour speed
limit in front of a school with that
asshole driving.
Okay.
Cause someone's little kids
going flying over the hood.
I wouldn't want it to be a little
Dan Hardee and it's an awful thing.
But the 40 miles now are smart because
kids also are stupid and they tend to
jump into traffic and that,
you know,
oh my lord,
my piece of paper,
Shit,
man,
I need to fucking pass this class and
they run out into the street and boom,
you got to be able to hit that break.
You fuck
fuck you.
Oh Man.
I don't ever remember anybody getting
hit by a car outside of school when I was
a kid and I'm,
we have a 45 mile and at 40 mile
an hour zone outside of my school.
I'm sure somebody did see a
woman get hit by a truck broke
though.
Ooh,
she got shot at groceries on the,
on the handle bar.
Oh my God.
How bad was that?
Bad.
Oh Jesus.
Fucking,
hey man,
I don't,
I don't want to see that,
but I have,
that's the problem with the Internet.
I've seen everything at this point.
You've seen so much.
If you watched the video of the
monk set himself on fire from,
yes,
I spent a day watching
that over and over again.
The one from Vietnam.
How do you,
how do you prepare yourself?
I didn't even fucking move.
No,
he never like,
he never panicked and he stayed in the
Lotus position and keep taking something
to numb it.
Nope.
I do not believe so.
So if you're going to
light yourself on fire,
what fucking difference does it make?
How you doing?
Light yourself on fire,
dude.
It's going to get kind of woman to,
did you see the,
uh,
the bear eat the monkey?
None in Hong Kong or Taiwan.
Maybe.
I forget somewhere in Singapore.
I'm just making shit up now.
I know where the fuck it happened.
Some in some Asian country,
there was a carnival show
where a bear was on a bicycle,
so he would pull it up.
Jamie,
there's a bear on a bicycle and a monkey
on a bicycle and they're going around
this ring and this is it.
Pull it way up into the,
the like the half
of it into it before the,
the bear loses his shit.
Yeah,
right before there.
So the monkey crap.
Pull it back.
Pull it back,
pull it back.
Pull back,
pull back.
The monkey,
uh,
crashes a bike and the bear crashes
into the monkeys bike when it's on the
ground and just decides to eat the monkey.
He's like,
you know what?
Fuck you.
So watch this.
Boom.
The monkey crashes.
The bear crashes on them.
It's like,
you know what?
I think I'm just gonna eat you
and just fucking malls that monkey.
And they're all grabbing him and pulling
the monkey away and look at this,
that monkeys Foxville son,
that bear is just going
off on that monkey.
It's like,
you stupid bitch.
You dropped your fucking bike.
That's it.
I've been thinking about
eating you for months.
I bet his instincts where when
something goes down in front of you,
you just start eating it.
Yeah.
You know?
I think that's like bare one-on-one,
right?
If you're a bear and some shit
trips in front of you like that,
you just started eating like
you got a gift from the gods.
Yeah.
How could you not do that?
Why would you not?
Yeah.
You don't train bear stupid.
You think you train bears.
He trained for a little bit.
We got him to ride a bike and
while he's riding that bike,
he's going,
I want to eat that monkey God.
Damn.
Eat that monkey.
Not many times you can use that sentence.
Yeah.
Unless you Joey Diaz,
you use it all day.
We thought Monkey Cock sucker.
Um,
so you had all these experiences.
Did it make you look at
fighting any differently?
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
this is going to sound kind of odd
because I carried on fighting after the
experience,
but I kind of saw the futility in it,
the pointlessness in it,
you know?
Right.
I mean there's a British comedy that,
uh,
that kind of captures it really well.
They do like a parody of a,
like a,
a soccer commercial and the like,
you know,
talking about Manchester
United and Arsenal then,
and they'll,
they'll win and they'll see who wins
now and then next year it will carry on
just the same and there'll
be more guys that win.
And you know what I mean?
It's the same thing.
Like I can be the champion for 10 years,
but once that 11th years comes,
there's going to be
somebody else's champion.
And it will just continue on forever.
And,
and it's,
it's,
it's the,
it's the absolute core of,
of,
of the capitalist approach to life is to
actually beat someone down to take food
out of their mouth,
which is really kind of odd.
And I've never seen it like that before.
Normally it's like,
yeah,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna beat the hell out of that guy.
I'm going to take what he's got.
But now I,
I,
I'm kind of,
I liked the,
I liked the competition.
the actual physical test of fighting,
but not for the same reasons.
Not,
not to like to be more
successful than you know,
to
can you can,
can you continue with the same passion,
having different ideas of
what's important about finding?
Yeah,
because,
well,
the one thing that I,
that was really starting to focus on,
uh,
you know,
with the MEF fight since I went to Peru
with the Mfi and I go going into the
Brown fight as well.
And,
and this
is the reason why I would,
I would at least like the option to,
to carry on fighting.
You know,
I would like to be able
to get cleared so I can,
you know,
I don't think I'll go back to flying,
three times a year and chasing the
belt because my focus is elsewhere now.
Where's your focus?
Well,
there's a space that you get to.
When do you read much?
Carl Sagan?
You read the dragons of Eden.
How about the tree and brain and the,
um,
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to like understand
the distinction between
the different areas of the
brain.
The reptilian brain,
which is obviously
responsible for all the,
uh,
the,
the aggressiveness,
the instinctual stuff.
Um,
uh,
the,
the fights and the killing
and all that kind of,
that's the reptilian brain.
The political side of it is basically,
um,
and then after that,
then you've got like
the old mammalian brain,
which is where we start to make kind of
like basic connections with people and
understand that if we work as a group,
we can,
you know,
we can survive better.
And then the next level up is,
is obviously a higher consciousness is,
is having deeper understanding,
deeper relationships and
communications with people around you.
But there's a point when you fight,
where were the reptilian brain takes over.
And I usually feel it after I've
been cracked a couple of times.
Like when I was fighting Ludwig in,
uh,
at the MGM,
I was very conscious for the first
30 or 30 seconds or so of the five.
And then as I stepped in,
you,
you remember he cracked me with that
right hand route and the Chin and I rushed
him up against the fence and immediately
I switched over to to instinct.
And it's,
it's like being a passenger.
It's like I'm not,
I have no conscious,
uh,
decision making ability in that,
in that time.
It's all instinct.
I'm not,
I'm not focused at all on,
on what he's doing.
I'm just reading,
I'm just feeling and,
and I,
I want it.
I want to find if I can get,
I want to see if I can get to that
place for a longer period of time.
You know what I mean?
Like with the Amea fight,
I felt like I would slip in and out of it,
like let the first round it was,
it was so overwhelming
because it was hometown,
you know,
my name was being showered by you know,
8,000 people or something and,
and,
and you know,
I live next to the arena.
So it occurred to me that if I lost,
that would be on my mind every
time I looked out my window.
So the first round I lost it.
I mean I just,
I just kind of moved around and backed
up and when I sat down in my corner after
the first round,
I apologize to my team.
I said,
I'm sorry,
I just had to get that out of the way.
But then the second and third round,
I felt like I could reach that,
that stage sometime where I just kind
of allow my body to take over and just
switch off and in the
face we would just watch.
Do you think that's
what Anderson is doing?
I think is that,
that's exactly what he's doing.
Yeah.
But I don't know as he's,
as he's aware of himself doing it.
Do you know what I mean?
It's so good.
It does.
How he locked it in.
Yeah.
I just think,
I just think when the fight starts,
he immediately switches over.
But you,
you can see it in people's eyes.
Like vandelays a great example.
If you watch one vandelays highlight
reels where he's got a few of his stare
downs,
he immediately switches to reptile
mode as soon as he's fighting.
That's a great way of
putting it with him too.
It's true.
But you know,
and like man Hoff is another one.
Those guys that have just,
they've just got that
light instinctual rage.
It just kind of comes on.
But,
and this is why like,
you know,
I've,
I've always kind of heard the term,
you know,
you,
you mean 20 even 10 20% of the things
that you learned in the gym and natural
fight,
you know,
when adrenaline and,
and,
and the actual fight is,
is occurring,
you only kind of maintain,
like keep about 20% of what
you've learned in the gym.
So the idea has been in the gym,
you train yourself to the point where it
does become instinct and then when the
fight happens you just switched to reptile
mode and reptile mode uses the skills
that you learn to to get the
job done more efficiently.
Do you think that becoming more
aware or reaching a higher state of
consciousness because of your experiences
will actually help you because it will
abandon a lot of the distractions that
you present yourself almost unknowingly?
Yeah,
well it helps me,
it helps me in training and particularly
in when I'm running now because I used
to listen to like Pantera and yeah,
like vision of disorder.
When I was running I'd worked myself
into like a rage so I wouldn't run to
exhaustion.
That was kind of how I trained and I
trained all the way through my career like
that.
And the last couple of
fights I've switched it up.
I be listening to a lot more like bite
and more like blind binaural beat type of
stuff when I'm running so I could get
into more like a meditative stage,
you know,
doing a lot of yoga as well and trying
to find the same thing where you just
[inaudible] you're within yourself and
you're not focusing on anything else.
So your body's almost like on autopilot.
Yeah.
That you,
the music that you listened to when you
train can have a profound effect on how
you approach your training.
Yeah,
it really can.
It's so important.
And that's why I've always been so
vocal about all the stuff I listened to.
Like I'd,
I'd like training camp playlist,
so I tweet everyday trunk songs I was
listening to and that kind of thing.
It is important.
And,
and,
and the,
the other thing as well,
like earlier on in my career,
I would use music to anchor feelings.
So like,
like,
uh,
when I fought Ludwick,
I used a song called ion by Woodkid,
which was the first time I'd switched it
up from England belongs to me for like,
you know,
a bunch of fires.
Um,
so like for the 12 weeks of that fight,
I was training with Frank Mir.
We were going up to read,
it's up to Mount Charleston and now into
red rock and like doing hill running
and stuff.
And we had some real tough sessions.
I mean,
you know,
we really put ourselves through
it for that training camp.
And as soon as I got back in
my truck after the second,
after the session,
if I felt like it was a good session,
it was productive and I felt positive,
I would put that song on.
And I would say I would constantly
connect those feelings to that,
that song.
So then when,
when I'm walking out
and that song comes on,
immediately I get that feeling again.
And it's just like,
you know,
just like when you listen to a song,
when you think of a person like,
oh,
I heard that song person and you meet,
you make that connection immediately.
But you can also train yourself to do it.
So that's why you like
Alison to Cypress Hill now.
And it'll take me back to
fighting in cage warriors.
Like,
you know,
back in 2006 wow.
And I have songs all the way through
like that and now I don't listen to,
cause it was like my first two fights.
I came out to Pantera,
dragged the waters.
By the time I got to the cage I was so
wound up and so angry that I would just
add to run out of gas immediately.
And now whenever I listen to those songs,
I get that feeling of like exhaustion.
Like,
oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
People have like sex songs.
Yeah.
Remind them,
sex songs that remind you
of disappointment songs.
Remind me of extra.
Why did you connect sex to disappointment?
Just standard,
isn't it?
How it goes.
Most of the time we're just sex songs,
like something crazy on the spin doctor.
Um,
so what's,
uh,
what's next from here?
If you,
your focus has moved slightly off of
fighting and you still are interested in
fighting and you're still interested
in seeing what sort of state you can
achieve inside the octagon.
What else are you going
to do with your time?
Well,
I'm,
I've been having a lot of ideas.
Um,
a lot of,
uh,
I've had a few ceremonies recently
with various things and I've,
I've,
I've got quite a clear
direction of where I want to go.
Um,
I would like,
I want to get cleared to fight.
I would like to be able to fight again.
Um,
even if it's just,
you know,
once a year,
once every 18 months
or something just and,
and just have a fight with like someone
that's going to be a fun fight where I
can kind of test some of these theories
and see where I'm at physically.
Um,
but I'm going to start,
I'm going to start a video blog
in my training sessions because,
uh,
I do all kinds of stuff.
I do a lot of,
a lot of big from Yoga,
a lot of hot yoga trail
running kettlebells sessions.
Uh,
and then then I want to be able to go
into the gym and work on specific things.
Like,
like last night I went in to a 10th planet
Van Nuys and just kind of had a roll
around with those guys.
And I enjoyed it because cause there was,
it was very,
very playful.
There was no like agenda.
I had no agenda because I was just,
I was in the moment.
You're just learning and exactly.
And then,
and obviously when you've
got to training camp,
everything's always like,
ah,
I've always felt like I was wishing my
life away because I'm constantly waiting
for a date that was five,
six weeks ahead.
So I'm never in the moment.
I'm always in the moment,
you know,
that's,
that's to come.
George was talking about
how much he enjoys,
uh,
training in between fights
because then they just like,
he just will go box for like
six weeks or eight weeks,
just only boxing concentrate only on that.
And then we'll do Jujitsu in New
York who go there with Donna,
her train with him for six weeks.
I just want to do that.
I want to take a trip out to,
um,
at Southeast Asia and do
a little tour of Thailand.
Are you going to become a shaman,
Dan Hardy?
I don't know.
I feel like you are on that path.
I'm not having it in an
interesting direction,
but I want to,
I want to start kind of,
kind of,
uh,
promoting,
and more of an alternative lifestyle,
but what I'm doing,
what was my diet and my,
you know,
teacher plants,
medicines and uh,
and,
and my approach to training and health,
you know,
I have,
I'm really,
really focused on getting
strong and flexible right now.
That's my main focus through,
you know,
kettlebells and bodyweight exercises and,
and lots of stretching.
Um,
and,
and I'm just kind of interested to
see where this journey is going to go.
My,
my,
my goal is,
is to basically get paid to be myself.
That's what I want to do.
And do.
Improve yourself.
Yes,
exactly.
So,
and,
and you know,
kind of,
you know,
I have,
I have sponsors right
now that a supportive,
obviously know what would zines and Fay,
the flights and venom and you know,
that I want them to,
to continue to support me and while I'm
on this question and doing all this kind
of interesting stuff.
So I figured if I put a video blog
out there for people to watch this,
you know,
it gives them a,
that's a great idea.
I've been more of a connection Wolf camp.
I think I can recall it.
The Wolfcamp fuck.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Oh,
they're so worried.
So,
so I think,
I think that's what I'm going to do.
Um,
I have some other ideas as well.
I have,
uh,
I have a few people to
speak to her about some,
some business ideas that are,
have again,
all within the same,
if it's illegal,
don't it on this podcast,
it's most definitely not illegal.
Um,
at least not in Peru.
No,
no.
Uh,
like,
you know,
try and help promote a more
clean and conscious lifestyle.
So what is your diet now?
I'm predominantly Vegan now.
Bitch,
I thought we'd get into this.
I heard this call went dark.
I mean,
I,
I'm not,
uh,
I'm not giving it a name because he's not,
not really got a name.
I'm just kind of,
my approach to animal products are,
I will,
I will have animal
products occasionally if,
if I know that it's from a source
that I'm uncomfortable with,
you know,
like hunted meat or free range.
Exactly.
Or something like that.
Yeah.
Um,
I will eat fish all day long because
fish don't even take care of the babies.
That's that.
That's my larger fish.
But anybody who doesn't eat fish,
it's crazy.
But what about from a
selfish point of view?
If you don't know where the fish is from?
Like if you went out to a restaurant
and it was just farm raise is not good.
A lot of farm raised stuff is not good.
Um,
because first of all,
a lot of times they're exposed to higher
levels of mercury and apparently there
were higher levels of toxins.
Cause if you're in like,
Geez,
tanks of water or farms of all fish,
she's shitting on each
other and it's just,
it's another healthy and tastes good.
It demeaning.
I mean,
it's better than not eat in it.
it's not that bad,
but I think that it's been proven that,
uh,
that like when you see like red,
deep red salmon and then you see
like the salmon that you get,
like this farm raised salmon
where they have to dye it pink.
It's been proven that that's
wild stuff tastes better.
There's something better about it.
It's probably better for you.
I don't know if it's better for you,
but it's probably better for it.
Yeah.
You know,
I tweeted something to the
day I was in a store in Boise,
Idaho and uh,
it was,
uh,
it was a photograph of the ingredients
of a bottle of soda and one of the
Ingredients with artificial wild cherries.
That's hilarious.
So come to America,
Monsanto probably owns the patent on it.
So we were talking about this and,
and I got into it,
my theory of a,
of of stoner language,
the style like stoner
understandings of the world,
things that you see if you smoke weed,
the other people that weed don't.
And that's that kind of thing.
Artificial Wild Cherries.
Wow,
that's sweet.
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
And it's really funny,
like people,
people that don't
use plants in various ways,
um,
don't see these things.
They don't,
they don't pick up on these
artificial wild cherries.
I,
you know,
I'm not a,
I'm not 100% proponent of all people
using marijuana because I know some people
can't.
Well,
yeah,
I know they can't,
but you know,
when you hear somebody
say something like that,
you're like,
yeah,
that was a stoner.
Yeah.
There's certain things that people say
where you automatically know this guy
gets high.
I,
I'm like,
they get high and they don't
get high like Stan Hope.
Thanks Dan.
Hope totally seems like
you would get high,
but he doesn't get hot.
He doesn't like it.
It says,
it makes him feel paranoid.
He doesn't like it at all.
It's maybe some people that just
naturally inclined to be like that.
I couldn't tell.
You know,
I feel like it's obvious when you look
at terrible people that someone's brain
works different than
your brain or my brain.
Yeah.
And when you see like a guy like Gandhi,
for sure,
his brain works different than my brain.
There's just no doubt about it.
He also had his own path and he also
had his own intentions and his own life.
But I just can't imagine that his
interpretation of life was the same as my
interpretation of life.
And if that's the case,
how the fuck do I know
what pot does to you?
How the fuck would I know?
I,
you know,
I know people can't smoke it.
They smoke it and then they'll wake up
three days later with their pants off in
the jungle.
You know,
like,
I don't know,
like a good weekend
unless one of those wandering spiders.
Gotcha.
It gives you a hard on until you die.
I spent two weeks,
we'll come around the
juggling my underwear.
How dare you sir.
You get nervous.
No,
nothing bite.
And you know nothing.
You feel like you had the secret on your
sides and you're putting out positive
vibes.
I was very connected to it.
Like I wasn't going to mess
with everything and they
weren't gonna mess with me.
It was,
yeah.
Did you see Jaguars and
you're ill could hit?
No.
We could hear him though.
Yeah.
Because the jungle was literally
like outside of this dude,
wait a minute.
So you're on Ios.
Can you hear Jaguars?
Yeah,
you could just have them find me.
Just come into contact
with each other and so on.
Does that make you shit your pants?
Not as much as the plane going over.
That was really scary.
Oh,
the little propeller boy.
We run a flight paths for Ketosis,
which is like the nearest airport
and like at eight 30 every night,
so like 30 minutes into the
ceremony like we were in,
we were in,
it's called them a locker,
the ceremonial building.
It was like a big circular wooden
building and it's caught Netapp to like,
like you know about me to hire uh,
sorry,
uh,
net,
me to high off the floor.
So your light in the jungle pretty much.
There's not much separating
you and there's all kinds
of noises and crazy stuff
going on and it just kind of
becomes comfortable after a while.
But bugs are really loud,
right?
Yeah,
they are.
And the frogs as well.
But the plane was such an such an alien
kind of sound because we only heard it a
couple of times a day and the,
you know,
the last time heard it was eight 30 at
night just after without the other,
you know,
the dose of Iowaska and it started to
come on and the next thing I can hear it
over my head and um,
and I can feel everybody else's
consciousness on that plane.
I'm like,
I know there are like,
you know,
like 250 people up there and I'm like
feeling all of that kind of energy go
over.
It was really weird and
it happened every night.
Every ceremony
in those third world plane flights,
Dems a little different.
So yeah,
that was the chicken's in the
back down with fucking duct tape.
You saw that plane crash that
happened and I picked that,
freaked me.
Did you see that from Afghanistan?
It was a cargo plane and they
think that the cargo shifted,
the load shifted,
like it wasn't tied down properly.
And when that happens,
if the load shifts the
plane just immediately,
all the weight goes to the front or the
back of the plane and they just nose
dive.
Wow.
Ooh.
Yeah.
It's pretty fucked up.
We'll end on that for a nice,
beautiful,
cheery way to end just to,
just to let everybody know that you could,
you could defy gravity for short
periods of time every now and again.
But if you fuck up then or it fucks
up or this mechanical failure or Jesus
Christ.
Imagine watching that.
Wow.
I just being on that bus,
driving past it.
Oh my God,
that bus almost got hit by a
plane that fell from the sky.
It's like,
that's like a scene,
a final destination.
16 or something one day when
we have magnetic UFO looking
things that can't even
run into each other cause they
have magnets on the outside.
So they go like this.
When they bounce off each other,
we'll look at,
someone should get on crashes.
I think they're probably already on it,
I think.
Yeah.
Well they always talk about,
um,
when,
whenever like serious physicist discuss
the possibility of space travel,
like interstellar space travel.
They,
I'm like Stanton Freedman.
Like how,
how could aliens be doing it?
One of the things they always concentrate
on some sort of magnetic drive.
Hmm.
The um,
the uh,
guide,
Dr Robert Lasar,
he's a often criticized gentlemen
who claimed to work at area 51.
But whether or not that
got told the truth,
I don't know.
But uh,
he described and some sort
of back engineering that
they were doing at area 51.
And it was some sort of magnetic drive.
The idea is that,
you know,
you figure out how to,
he's magnets or something to overcome,
gravitating to create like a little
hole in space and time and then just fly
around through that.
Whatever the fuck I even said Dan Hardee,
I don't even mind.
I shouldn't,
it shouldn't be legal for me to say what
I just said because I don't even know
what the fuck it means.
Wow.
I got ready into aliens
when I was younger.
When I was in my teens.
It was like everything was aliens.
I really hope I got to experience
some kind of contact before I die.
Do you see this latest disclosure,
these five days of a disclosure
hearings on Capitol Hill?
No,
dude,
crazy shit.
All of these different,
yeah.
Well you know the real problem with
any sort of Ufo thing is that it looks
silly.
It looks silly.
You saying you saw a Ufo
makes you a silly person,
more silly even than Iowasca cause at
least Iowasca has a great body of evidence
to support what's going on.
You know chemically what you're
saying that you saw a Ufo,
you immediately become a silly person.
All these like former military people,
all these people that were
air traffic controllers,
pilots,
all these people report these
unbelievably unique experiences.
And I don't know if they're
telling the truth or not,
but if they were telling the truth,
if just one of these things
happened every now and again,
of course it would seem
ridiculous to us on the outside,
the people sitting down here,
it's,
it's natural to criticize it and make
fun of it and laugh at it because it is
kind of crazy to think,
but if just one of those is true,
if just one of those are a real craft
from another dimension from another
planet,
you don't think that that's possible.
You are silly.
If you don't think that within from here,
in every direction,
infinite space,
what?
What does that even mean?
We don't even know what
the fuck that means.
I can't even comprehend that.
It's gotta be something out that it's,
I think if we survive,
if we little pesky humans figured out
how to keep going for another couple of
million years,
who knows what the fuck we're going to
figure out to think that somebody else
can't be out there.
And what would we do if
someone was out there?
We would go check them out.
Yeah,
of course.
Of course it.
Fuck yeah,
we check them out.
Yeah.
We go to the Congo,
we go to the Congo,
we check out tribes,
we check out tribes of fishermen.
They're hanging off fucking trees,
picking up fish with nets.
We'd go watch him.
What'd you think about the theory of,
of the,
uh,
you know,
the,
the interaction without a history and how,
and how they've helped guide us.
It's all speculation.
It's complete speculation,
but cause you don't know whether
or not you look at an ancient,
when you look at ancient drawings,
you don't know what's fantasy.
You don't know what's a story.
You don't know what's
their version of a fucking,
the Hobbit,
you know,
they might make up stories.
You know who else it could
be their version of twilight.
That's what,
when you look at it,
it aliens in the wall.
It's their version.
Like they told a stupid story
to make everybody go to sleep.
Yeah.
Who knows?
We know that it's art.
We,
we,
we've seen in,
in their art these depictions that
closely resemble what we would think to be
alien.
Spacecrafts are alien beings,
but we don't really know
what the fuck it is.
It's not that much evidence.
So small amount of evidence.
There's a few cool videos,
you know that like,
hmm,
what is that?
Oh the fuck that is,
I don't even know if it's real.
It's hard to tell.
But if it happened to you,
man,
you'd fucking know.
And that's what you can't discount.
You can't discount the
possibility of unique experience.
But once you've had a DMT trip,
aliens seem like so passe.
It's like,
it's just kind of matter of fact,
I think it is kind of like,
well,
yeah,
of course.
Well not only that,
it's like to have that experience like a,
a ship lands and they get out.
It would be so less bizarre.
Yeah,
because it's all taking place right here.
You can say it's external.
What's taking place.
Also in the dimension that
we're comfortable with,
where we can walk on the grass and
feel the grass where we step on rocks.
We feel the rocks and our shoe.
Your car's parked over there,
you see the clouds above you and then
everything is basically normal except this
new introduced element into your
environment you have now except,
oh,
it was a fucking little
dude from another planet.
Holy Shit.
This really is true.
That's nothing compared to
a DMT trip cause a DMT trip.
The dimension that you exist
in becomes of a vibrant,
glowing colors with no background and
constantly changing geometric patterns
that are there fractal and their infinite.
That's way crazier than an alien landing.
Yeah.
The thing is like where
we're in an environment now
where particularly with the
Internet,
we,
we've effectively seen most things.
Like,
I remember when I was in China and I was
walking down the street with a friend
of mine who was like,
you know,
230 pound red black dude and these
Chinese dudes would just ignore it.
They just,
they just stood,
stood and watched him as
he walked down the street.
Like the Green Mile.
Exactly.
So then you know,
like,
and then think back to like a,
I dunno,
you know,
when,
when when the Romans were fighting
different tribes and they were taking
elephants with them.
Like when they took the
elephants to Britannia,
like there's a,
there's a,
there's a tube station in London
called elephant and castle,
which was,
you know,
this elephant crossing,
crossing this plane with this dude
sitting on top riding in it and the Bob
errands that were living there at the
time just lost their shit and ran away.
Like,
why wouldn't you,
you know what I mean?
But we don't have those experiences
anymore because we've seen everything.
Or you know,
we might see something that's a,
a new species,
but it's only a variation of something
that's already familiar to us.
Like,
imagine seeing an elephant
for the first time.
If you've lived in like,
I don't know,
England,
Jesus Christ,
it would blow your mind.
When did they know that elephants existed?
When was the first
documented by Western world?
Obviously Africans,
you know,
listen to this,
go bitch.
We've known about it.
I'll find it for 70,000 years.
When did you figure it out?
At a fun.
When did,
oh,
when did the civilized folk learn
of the larger animals on the plains?
You know,
when did they discover,
when did people discover elephants all?
It wasn't until 1900
people got down there.
Proper people might do when the
explorers likes first saw a giraffe.
Yeah.
How much would that blow your mind?
Well,
I guess we grew up with them though,
didn't we?
I mean,
if,
if you believe that human
life and emanated from the
lower hominids that existed
in Africa and came down from the
rain forest into the grasslands,
we would have probably been around them.
But what they would they have not to,
which is still not seem unfamiliar if you,
if you,
if you were from like Mongolia.
Oh yeah.
Then it'd be alien fun
if you came over from,
I mean essentially if you go anywhere
where you haven't been there before and
they have some new shit,
you're like,
what are you doing with
fucking Kangaroos everywhere?
What the fuck?
Well I have a friend
named Eddie [inaudible],
he's a standup comic and uh,
he's done very well,
very
well in Australia and he
goes over there quite a bit.
And one of the things
he told me was that he first
encountered a kangaroo.
Kangaroos have killed
people like many times.
Like they will fucking rip you apart.
And he didn't know how big bank got.
There's two kangaroos.
It's like a red one and a gray one.
I guess.
One of them is giant,
one of them's like nine feet tall.
And he was out in this guy's yard and he
saw this kangaroo and he thought it was
a statue cause it was too big.
He started walking towards it.
So it was like,
cause it was nine feet tall.
Wow.
And he was like,
well that's not really
a kangaroo kangaroos.
I get that tall and his
friends go stop walking.
I turn around now,
get the fuck away from that thing and
tango like looks at them and all sudden
suddenly realize,
oh Jesus,
this is a nine foot squirreled.
It's about the fuck me up.
That's a scary thought.
It's a nine foot jumping squirrel
that will kick your guts out.
Yeye
but the thing is like,
like my points to Sunday,
he's,
or he's still seeing what
occurring kangaroo looks like,
even if even if he's not
expats in the nine foot one.
Right.
Like even if,
uh,
even if a velociraptor showed
it right now in this room,
you know,
we've seen it,
we've kind of see it,
we kind of know what they
look light and no surprises,
but an alien landing.
Is that still kind of
a shock to the system?
But then again on top of that,
the DMT Rome is completely
removed altogether.
Yeah.
And aliens.
The problem I always have with aliens
as they look so much like us in the
future.
Yeah.
I always wonder whether or not light,
I mean the big,
the grand theories,
the simulation theory that we're
living inside some sort of a artificial
reality.
And that the aliens are us and that's why
we have this weird image of that being
us in the future.
We're already there and
we didn't like it sucks.
It's boring.
We,
we,
we sort of evolve the fun out of life.
So we've created this crazy
simulation that we all exist in.
That's the grand theory.
That's the grand theory involving
the aliens for me at least,
if that's why they look like us and
that's why they have big black things for
their eyes.
We fucked the environment so hard that
you have to have sunglasses everywhere.
Everywhere you go,
you have to have built in sunglasses.
So we just artificially create
sunglasses for each other.
Just put giant fucking black
things every guy has done.
They,
I don't worry about the fucking hyper
violent raise or whatever's out there and
with Jack and you,
we have really long fingers from texting.
Exactly.
Well at that point in time you probably
control everything with your mind so you
can,
this is probably no need for muscles.
That's why they're so skinny.
There's a little tiny dudes with giant
heads and they control everything with
their minds.
Do you think?
Do you think we could potentially
evolve to that statement?
Questionably?
No doubt about it.
Even with the clicking send to this day,
I might,
this computer's not hooked
up to anything Dan Hardee,
but yet it's on the Internet.
It's getting the Internet
through the space around us.
You know,
you're telling me that that can eventually
be humidity consciousness itself,
traveling through space,
through some sort of a mechanism for,
for,
for generating it or promoting it or
projecting it have to fart theory and it's
calming.
None.
As far
my alien fart theory is this.
Um,
if someone farted and you
didn't have a sense of smell,
you'd have no idea that you're sitting
in someone's cause you can't see it.
You know,
you'd really don't know.
In Florence are like a real far.
You're like,
oh my God and you'll get the fuck out.
You close your mouth,
but you don't see a damn thing somehow.
I know that you've been
affected by something that
you didn't pick up with your
normal senses or with all
of your normal senses.
You heard it and then you smelled it,
but you saw nothing.
How do we not know?
There's not an infinite amount of things
all around us all the time that we just
do not have the ability to detach.
Quantify.
So that's your argument.
People that laugh at you
when you use the word,
we use the term energy.
I'm going to start talking about
energy and stuff and like Bros delay.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
whatever.
Whatever.
Bros.
Bros are always problems.
It's always my fault though,
Ken.
Smell fart.
Yeah.
And you don't know what the fuck that is.
That's energy.
Yeah.
And the bigger the dude monk,
likely the more energy's going to put.
As
you know.
I mean,
if Tony Hinchcliffe Arts of Joey d as
far as which one do you want to lean?
Do you mean with Tony?
Queefs.
Come on.
Hey,
come on man.
Listen.
Jann harder.
You're a bad motherfucker.
I'll have you on anytime.
You're around,
man.
Anytime you want to come back.
Let's we could,
we could do this for,
I have to leave.
Otherwise I would keep going forever.
I think you and I could talk for a long
time and we've been friends for a long
time.
Man.
You're a cool motherfucker.
I like you and I'm really,
I'm uh,
I'm,
I'm very appreciative of how
you're evolving as a human being.
I think it's really fascinating to
watch and I congratulate you on your,
on your travels.
Thank you.
Well,
I'll be out,
I'll be out helping Mack out and stuff.
So you're going to be for awhile.
I'll be around in
California and I'll kind of,
I'll start again.
Do it again in a couple
of weeks to do that.
Let's do it again.
Powerful Dan.
Hardee.
All right,
my brother.
Thank you,
sir.
Thank you.
Thank you everybody for
sponsoring this bad boy.
Uh,
thanks to Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com forward slash
Joe and use the code Joe for to save
yourself some sheckles son.
Okay.
Joe Rogan.
If you,
uh,
I don't know where that
came from yourself.
I was,
um,
reading,
reading while I was doing this.
Uh,
thanks.
Also to hover,
go to hover.com forward slash Rogen
and get 10% off your domain name
registrations and thanks to
on at.com use the code name,
Rogan that,
o n n,
I.
T.
And save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
you're freaks.
We will be back tomorrow with the Great
Danieli Bolelli returns that drunk and
Dow is podcasted dropped some knowledge
about religious history and how much
pitches like an accident like that.
Oh Shit.
All right.
Thank you guys for tuning in.
We love you.
And,
uh,
as Joey Diaz says,
stay black.